REVIEW WILL COME TO ORDER. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR HEARING HERE IN THE
SWING SPACE. 1021 O STREET, ROOM
1200. WE ARE JUST SHY OF A
QUORUM, SO WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND, ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AS SOON AS WE HAVE IT. WE
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD,
AFTER DISCUSSION OF ALL ITEMS.
AND SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
DOING IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
AND SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM, WE WILL JUST PROCEED TO
PRESENTATIONS. THE BILLS THAT WE
WILL HEAR TODAY ARE AB 157,
WHICH IS A BUDGET BILL. JUNIOR
FOR THE 2024 BUDGET ACT, AB 158,
A BUDGET BILL. JUNIOR FOR THE
2022 AND 23 BUDGET ACTS. AND
THEN FIVE BUDGET TRAILER BILLS,
THESE BILLS INCLUDE TECHNICAL
CHANGES, ISSUES THAT WERE NOT
COMPLETED IN JUNE AND
RATIFICATION OF VARIOUS
BARGAINING UNIT MOUS. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO'S WORKED HARD
IN DRAFTING THIS BUDGET, BOTH
FROM JUNE AND FOR THE ACTIONS
WE'RE TAKING NOW, INCLUDING OUR
SENATE BUDGET STAFF, ASSEMBLY
STAFF, THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LAO, SO WITH THAT, MR. VICE
CHAIR, DO YOU HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS? THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
I APPRECIATE THAT TO REVIEW.
PROPOSITION 25 WAS PROPOSED BY
THE MAJORITY PARTY AS A PROMISE
TO THE VOTERS TO PASS A BUDGET
ON TIME IF THEY JUST DIDN'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE PRIORITIES OF
THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE PESKY REPUBLICANS
REPRESENT. WHAT WE'VE SEEN
REPEATEDLY AS HAS BEEN WRITTEN
BY DAN WALTERS AND OTHERS, HAS
BEEN A MERE PLACEHOLDER BUDGET
DEVELOPED LARGELY WITHOUT
TRANSPARENCY, TO BE AND ALWAYS
IS, COMPLETED LATER. LIKE TODAY.
BUT FOR THE PARGA RELATED
ALLOCATIONS AND THE MOUS. THESE
BILLS DEAL WITH ISSUES THAT
LARGELY EXISTED IN JUNE. SO THIS
HEARING GIVES PROOF TO THE LIE
THAT THAT ON TIME BUDGET PASSED
OVER TWO MONTHS AGO. THIS IS
NOTHING NEW FOR ME. OF COURSE, I
HAVE BEEN REDUNDANTLY REDUNDANT
IN MY CRITICISM OF OUR BUDGET
PROCESS, AND BY RIGHT COULD JUST
OPPOSE EVERYTHING BEFORE US
TODAY. BUT TO EXPLAIN IN ADVANCE
AND AVOID THE ADMONITION OF
RALPH WALDO EMERSON THAT A
FOOLISH CONSISTENCY IS THE
HOBGOBLIN OF SMALL MINDS, I WILL
SUPPORT SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT I FIND. EXCUSE ME
NONETHELESS COMPELLING AND
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
I THANK YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR. WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE WILL
ESTABLISH THAT NOW. SENATORS
WIENER PRESENT. MILO, HERE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER CORTEZ.
DOLLY DURAZO HERE. EGGMAN GROVE.
LAIRD HERE. MENGIBAR. NEWMAN
HERE. PADILLA. ROTH CIERTO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WAHAB.
HERE WILK. PRESENT OKAY, WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. WE'LL NOW BEGIN
WITH ERICA LEE, THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, WHO WILL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE BILLS BEFORE US
TODAY. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
WIENER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. ERICA LEE,
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND I AM HERE TO PRESENT ON
SEVERAL BUDGET BILLS, AS NOTED,
THAT INCLUDE WHAT I WOULD SAY
ARE LARGELY CLEANUP ITEMS AND
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO CURRENT
AND PRIOR BUDGET AGREEMENTS. THE
FIRST BILL, SB 157, AMENDS THE
2024 BUDGET ACT. THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE AVAILABILITY OF
EXISTING FUNDS FOR THE COURT
BASED FIREARM RELINQUISHMENT
PROGRAMS TO GIVE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL MORE TIME TO ADMINISTER
THE THIRD ROUND OF GRANTS. IT
ALSO EXTENDS THE AVAILABILITY OF
FUNDS FOR THE EXTREME HEAT AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE GRANT
PROGRAM FROM FOUR YEARS TO FIVE
YEARS, TO ALIGN WITH THE INTENT
OF THE ORIGINAL ALLOCATION. THE
BILL ALSO ALIGNS PROGRAM
EXPENDITURES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION WITH
CHAPTER 60 STATUTES OF 2024 OR
AB 2113, WHICH INCREASED THE
PESTICIDE MILL FEE TO ALIGN
REVENUE AND EXPENDITURES WITH
PROGRAM NEEDS AND ADDRESS THE
FUND'S STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. IT
ALSO PROVIDES FUNDS AND
POSITIONS TO THE LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO IMPLEMENT
THE REVISED CURE PROCESS FOR
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT,
OR PAGA. CLAIMS ESTABLISHED BY
SB 92. IT PROVIDES AMENDMENTS TO
K-12 AND HIGHER EDUCATION
INVESTMENTS THAT SUPPORT
SCHOOLS, STUDENTS, AND FAMILIES.
IT ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EMERGENCY, EMERGENCY, EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY TO
RECOVER FUNDS FRONTED BY THE
STATE FOR SURGE STAFFING DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND MAKES OTHER
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO ALIGN
WITH THE BUDGET AGREEMENT. THE
NEXT BILL IS SB 158, AND IT
AMENDS THE 2022 AND 2023 BUDGET
ACTS. THE BILL MAKES AN
INVESTMENT. I'M SORRY. THE BILL
MAKES AN ADJUSTMENT OF 25,000 TO
ACCURATELY REFLECT BUDGETED
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS AT SANTA ROSA, NAPA AND
IMPERIAL VALLEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COLLEGES. IT ALSO
INCLUDES AUTHORITY FOR CDCR TO
PAY SETTLEMENT COSTS RELATED TO
A LEGAL CASE THAT AWARDED
SPECIFIED SUPERVISORY
CORRECTIONAL EMPLOYEES
ADDITIONAL COMPENSATION FOR WORK
ACTIVITIES. THEY MUST COMPLETE
BEFORE AND AFTER THEIR OFFICIAL
SHIFT TIMES, AND IT INCLUDES
OTHER CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS. THE NEXT BILL IS SB
176, THE EDUCATION TRAILER BILL.
THIS BILL FURTHER SPECIFIES A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO REPORT UNEXPENDED
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM DOLLARS OR L'OP DOLLARS
FOR DEPARTMENT COLLECTION. IT
DELAYS THE INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY PLAN CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS BY ONE YEAR TO
FISCAL YEAR 20 2627. IT PROPOSES
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITIES THAT
ALLOW SPECIFIED LOCAL ENTITIES
TO APPLY FOR REMAINING
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
PLANNING GRANT PROGRAM FUNDS. IT
REQUIRES THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
TO PROMULGATE UPDATED
REGULATIONS PERTAINING TO
OCCUPANCY STANDARDS FOR DAYCARE
CENTERS, IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES, AND IT MAKES
ADDITIONAL CLARIFYING
ADJUSTMENTS. THE NEXT BILL IS SB
177 OR HEALTH. THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS A NEW SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT PROGRAM FOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JR. COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL TO PROVIDE INCREASED
ONGOING FUNDING, SUBJECT TO
FEDERAL APPROVAL. IT ALLOWS THE
STATE TO COLLECT NEAR REAL TIME
BED CAPACITY DATA FOR CERTAIN
MEDICAL AND HEALTH FACILITIES TO
SUPPORT PROMPT PLACEMENT INTO
INPATIENT AND CRISIS
STABILIZATION BEDS, AND MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS, THE
NEXT BILL, SB AB RESOURCES
TRAILER BILL AND I'M SORRY, I'VE
BEEN SAYING SB IT'S AB 178
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL. THIS
BILL REINSTATES CAL RECYCLE TIRE
RECYCLING PROGRAM CONTRACTING
AUTHORITIES THAT WERE REPEALED
IN TRAILER BILL EARLIER THIS
YEAR, WHICH ARE STILL NEEDED TO
ENABLE CAL RECYCLE TO CONTRACT
WITH OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO SUPPORT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION. IT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY FOR
COMPLIANCE AND REPORTING OF
SPECIFIED GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND REQUIREMENTS FOR
TOXIC CLEANUP FUNDING THAT WAS
PRIORITIZED IN THE 2024 BUDGET
ACT, AND IT MAKES OTHER
CLARIFYING ADJUSTMENTS. THE
FINAL BILL IS AB 181. GENERAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS BILL INCLUDES
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY FULFILL ITS DUTIES
RELATED TO PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS. JOB ORDER CONTRACTING
AND CONTRACTING OVERSIGHT AND
PROVIDES TOOLS TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES AMONG STATE
DEPARTMENTS. THIS BILL CREATES
THE PROJECTED SURPLUS TEMPORARY
HOLDING ACCOUNT TO SET ASIDE A
PORTION OF ANTICIPATED SURPLUS
FUNDS IN FUTURE FISCAL YEARS. IT
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW FOR
SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS TO OBTAIN
FEDERAL CRIMINAL HISTORY OR
BACKGROUND CHECK INFORMATION FOR
STATE EMPLOYEES, CONTRACTORS,
AND APPLICANTS FOR LICENSURE TO
CONTINUE REGULAR OPERATIONS AND
UPHOLD ITS REGULATORY DUTIES.
AND IT MAKES OTHER CLARIFYING
AND TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS, THE
NEXT BILL IS AB 181, SORRY, THE
PREVIOUS BILL WAS AB 179. THIS
IS A MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING, AND THIS BILL
RATIFIES AND FUNDS MEMORANDA OF
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND BIÂU FIVE,
WHICH IS THE HIGHWAY PATROL BIÂU
EIGHT FIREFIGHTERS AND BIÂU TEN
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS. THIS
BILL ALSO FUNDS STATUTORILY
REQUIRED GENERAL SALARY
INCREASES FOR BIÂU FIVE THE
HIGHWAY PATROL AND FOR JUDGES.
AND WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. BEFORE WE GO TO
QUESTIONS NOW, GOING TO ASK FOR
CAROLYN CHU FROM THE LA Ó TO
PRESENT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. CAROLYN CHU WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. AND WE
RECENTLY RELEASED OUR ANALYSIS
OF THE THREE MOU UNDER
CONSIDERATION. OKAY. GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL NOW
OPEN UP FOR DISCUSSION OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. SENATOR
SATO. THERE YOU GO. THANK YOU. I
HAD A QUESTION KIND OF RELATES
TO THE MCO AND ALSO WITH THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING HOSPITAL, AND
THE MECHANISM THAT HAS CREATED
THE NEED FOR THEM TO GET $25
MILLION TO SHORE UP THEIR
BUDGET. THIS THE HOSPITAL IS IN
A PROBLEMATIC AREA FINANCIALLY.
IT DEPENDS ON MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT. AND YET THE MCO
TAX, THE DIVERSION OF THE $2.3
BILLION. REDUCES THE VERY AMOUNT
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO USE FOR
THE REIMBURSEMENT. THAT'S WHY IT
WAS CREATED. CORRECT. THE MCO
TAX WAS CREATED TO HELP INCREASE
MEDI-CAL RATES. SO HOSPITALS
LIKE MARTIN LUTHER KING COULD,
WHO LARGELY SERVE MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS, WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE THAT ARE
JUST LIKE THEM, AND YET THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE REIMBURSEMENT
BECAUSE WE ARE DIVERTING THAT
MONEY AWAY FROM THE DIVERT THE
REIMBURSEMENT. POLICY BASICALLY,
THAT WE WANTED TO CREATE, WHICH
WAS THEY WOULD GET MORE AND
THEIR HOSPITALS WOULD SURVIVE.
SO HOW ARE WE HELPING THE OTHER
HOSPITALS BESIDES MARTIN LUTHER
KING? BY DIVERTING $2.3 BILLION
AWAY FROM OUR MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT INCREASES THAT WE
WERE PROMISING THESE HOSPITALS?
GOOD MORNING, GUADALUPE
MANRIQUEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO, THE IN PREVIOUS
BUDGETS, THERE WAS $300 MILLION
ALLOCATED ONE TIME TO HELP
VARIOUS HOSPITALS ACROSS THE
STATE, TO DATE, MOST OF THAT
FUNDING HAS BEEN RELEASED. SO
THAT WAS, IN EFFORT TO HELP
HOSPITALS THAT WERE IN DISTRESS.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
WORKING TO DEVELOP A NEW
HOSPITAL QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE.
AND SO THAT WILL ALSO HELP
INCREASE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
TO HOSPITALS. SO MORE TO COME ON
THAT, NEXT BUDGET CYCLE. OKAY.
SO THE ANSWER IS THE MCO TAX IS
GOING TO BE BOOKED. SO THE MCO
TAX CAN BE SUPPLEMENTED BY A NEW
TAX. SO IT IS A FEE. IT'S AN
EXISTING FEE. WE'VE USED THE
HOSPITAL QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE
AS AN IMPORTANT FINANCING
MECHANISM FOR OUR HOSPITALS FOR
I DON'T REMEMBER THE EXACT DATE,
BUT WE YEAH, IT'S IN THE INITIAL
300 YOU TALKED ABOUT. THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE PUT FORWARD
WHILE WE WERE WORKING ON TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THE MECHANISM, HOW
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HELP
HOSPITALS. SO WE DID THAT TO
KIND OF PLUG THE IMMEDIATELY THE
IMMEDIATE HOLE OF A BUNCH OF
HOSPITALS CLOSING AND THEN
CREATED THE MCO TO TRY TO FIX
THAT. BUT NOW THE MCO IS ALL
BEING DIVERTED. MOST OF IT IS
BEING DIVERTED AWAY FROM ITS
INTENDED PURPOSE. AND NOW WE'RE
CREATING ANOTHER TAX TO TRY TO
FILL THE MCO. WHAT'S TO PREVENT
THAT FROM BEING PUT INTO THE
GENERAL FUND IS HAVE LANGUAGE IN
THERE THAT'S GOING TO SAY IT
CAN'T GO TO THE GENERAL FUND AND
BE DIVERTED AWAY FROM ITS
INTENDED PURPOSE, JUST LIKE THE
MCO TAX. SO I WOULD SAY THAT
THE, 1.2 BILLION IS STILL
MAINTAINED FOR PROVIDER PAYMENTS
AS PART OF THE MCO TAX. IN
TOTAL, IT'S 1.5 BILLION ONGOING,
ROUGHLY 1.5 BILLION ONGOING. AND
THE HOSPITAL QUALITY ASSURANCE
FEE IS, FOR HOSPITALS, SO I
WOULD SAY THAT, THERE IS A
PORTION THAT HELPS SUPPORT
MEDI-CAL, BUT A MAJORITY OF IT
IS FOR HOSPITALS. AND SO THAT
AGAIN, IS UNDER DEVELOPMENT. AND
MORE DISCUSSION TO COME LATER.
ALL RIGHT. WELL, WHILE THEY'RE
DEVELOPING IT, I WOULD HOPE THEY
WOULD PUT IN THAT. IT CAN'T GO
TO THE GENERAL FUND LIKE THE MCO
TAX HAS BEEN UTILIZED. THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS, YES. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I JUST HAD A QUESTION ON,
ITEM FIVE ABOUT THIS. SETTLEMENT
COSTS RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. CAN YOU EXPAND
MORE ON WHAT? I'M SURE I WILL. I
WILL ALLOW MY COLLEAGUE TO SPEAK
MORE TO THAT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, LINDA CIMINO,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI. IT'S
RELATED TO, A SETTLEMENT THAT
WAS REACHED, AND IT'S CALLED
WALK TIME. SO FOR PRE AND POST
WORK ACTIVITIES. SO WHEN
SUPERVISORY STAFF AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS ARE
GOING TO THEIR POST, THEY ARE
NOW GOING TO BE COMPENSATED FOR
THE TIME IT TAKES THEM TO GO TO
AND FROM ANY PRE-SHIFT BRIEFINGS
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT. BUT I
WASN'T SURE BECAUSE WAS THIS THE
SETTLEMENT THAT WAS PART OF A
LABOR NEGOTIATION FOR THIS? YES.
OKAY. THANKS. I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? YES, MR.
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. JUST A COMMENT ABOUT AB
179, ITEM THREE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS REGARDING THE PROJECTED
SURPLUS TEMPORARY HOLDING
ACCOUNT. THERE'S GOT TO BE AN
ACRONYM IN THERE SOMEWHERE, THIS
IS, TO AS I UNDERSTAND IT, AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO CONTROL THE
SIGNIFICANT VOLATILITY WE HAVE
IN REVENUE. AND I KNOW THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE HAD AN
EXTENDED DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
LAST WEEK OR THE WEEK BEFORE.
I'D JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT,
THERE'S ONLY REALLY ONE OF TWO
WAYS TO TRULY REIGN IN THE
VOLATILITY. ONE IS TO EVEN OUT
OUR TAX STRUCTURE SO THAT WE ARE
LESS RELIANT ON REALLY HIGH
INCOME EARNERS. AND THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN. IT WILL
OBVIOUSLY BE IT WOULD BE A TAX
REDUCTION FOR THE WEALTHY. BUT
THE OTHER WAY IS TO ON A
FORMULAIC BASIS, LIMIT THE
AMOUNT OF SPENDING WHEN REVENUES
PEAK. BUT TO ALLOW FOR AND PUT
THE DIFFERENCE INTO A RESERVE
AND THEN ALLOW FOR THAT TO BE
SPENT WHEN REVENUES DIP. AND I
KNOW THERE'S NOT A GREAT DEAL OF
SUPPORT AMONG THE MEMBERS OF THE
MAJORITY PARTY FOR THAT, BECAUSE
IT PUTS HANDCUFFS ON THE ABILITY
TO SPEND MONEY WHEN THERE'S A
LOT OF MONEY, THERE. BUT IT
WOULD, TEND TO LIMIT THE PAIN OF
THE HIGH VOLATILITY OF REVENUE
WHEN THINGS DIP AGAIN. AND I'D
JUST LIKE TO MAKE THAT COMMENT
THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE
TRIED TO CHAMPION OVER THE YEARS
TO NO AVAIL. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING FOR US TO CONSIDER IN OUR
BUDGETING PROCESS. HEY, SENATOR
RUSSELL. THANK YOU, A COUPLE OF
POINTS HAVING TO DO WITH, WHAT
WE ARE DOING ON THE ISSUE OF
QUALITY OF JOBS THROUGH OUR
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT
PROCESS, SO JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
AND, AB 158. WHEN CAL CHEN PUTS
OUT A CONTRACT FOR THE IDLE
WELLS, ARE YOU INCLUDING JOB
QUALITY AND EQUITY STANDARDS?
SO, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE WE HAVE
EXAMPLES OF, WE HOW WE INVESTED
IN AN OIL WELL CAPPING PILOT
PROGRAM, AND IT RESULTED IN A
SUCCESSFUL PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
ENGINEERS, LABORERS, SMALL
BUSINESSES, BUT ONE THAT CAL JAM
CONTRACT FOR THE WORK WAS PUT
OUT THE STANDARDS ONLY REFERRED
TO MINIMUM LABOR LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH EVERYBODY HAS
TO FOLLOW ANYWAY. IN OTHER
WORDS, THERE WAS NO THERE WAS NO
UPPING OF THE OF THE STANDARD
FOR OUR FOR OUR INVESTMENTS. SO
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT AND
ALSO, AB 179, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AGAIN, HAS MADE
VERY CLEAR, THE FRAMEWORK FOR
WHAT IS A GOOD JOB. THEY'VE BEEN
VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT IT. WE JUST
SAW A LETTER, AUGUST 9TH FROM
THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF LABOR,
AND HOW THEIR COMMITMENT TO
PRINCIPLES THAT SHOULD BE
FOLLOWED, SO WHAT IS CALIFORNIA
DOING TO EMBED JOB QUALITY INTO
OUR CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT
POLICIES? THANK YOU FOR THAT
IMPORTANT QUESTION, SENATOR
DURAZO. I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THE PARTICULARS ABOUT
THE CAL JAM CONTRACT IN REGARDS
TO JOB STANDARDS, AS AS YOU
MENTIONED AND MORE GENERALLY,
ABOUT GOOD JOBS, ACROSS MULTIPLE
CONTRACTS, SO WE CAN GET YOU
SOME MORE INFORMATION ON THAT. I
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING HANDY WITH
ME RIGHT NOW. BUT DO YOU HAVE A
POLICY THAT YOU ABIDE BY THAT
YOU USE TO BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
GUIDE YOU? I MEAN, WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS MADE CLEAR THEY
WANT JOB STANDARDS. THEY WANT
EQUITY. THEY WANT ALL THAT TO BE
INCLUDED. AND YET YOU KNOW, WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH CONTRACTS AND
WE DON'T APPEARS NOT TO HAVE THE
HIGHER STANDARDS THAT ARE
EXPECTED, ESPECIALLY WHEN
FEDERAL DOLLARS ARE CONCERNED.
SO HOW DO YOU MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS? HOW DO YOU MOVE
FORWARD WITH A POLICY THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE IN PLACE? AND AGAIN,
AS YOU STATED, THERE ARE STATE
STANDARDS THAT ARE TEMPLATED,
BUILT IN INTO OUR CONTRACTS
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT, I WILL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON WHAT
THOSE PARTICULARS ARE AND HOW IT
MEETS THE FEDERAL STANDARDS.
OKAY ACTUALLY, WHAT I'M SAYING
IS THAT WE DON'T DO WE DON'T
HAVE THE STANDARDS THAT WE
SHOULD, AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT IS LOST
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE ARE NOT
INCORPORATING HIGHER STANDARDS
WHEN IT COMES TO CONTRACTS AND
PROCUREMENT, AND WE'RE LEAVING
OUR CALIFORNIA WORKERS, THROWING
THEM UNDER THE BUS BY NOT HAVING
CONTRACTS WITH COMPANIES THAT
WILL DO BUSINESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. INSTEAD OF SENDING
OUR MONEY TO TEXAS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? OKAY. IN THAT CASE,
WE WILL NOW OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE COME FORWARD,
AND AGAIN THIS IS ON ALL ITEMS,
AND WELCOME, DANICA, ON BEHALF
OF TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMING
WORDS REBOUND GRIP TRAINING
INSTITUTE AND INITIATE JUSTICE
EXPRESSING DEEP GRATITUDE TO
SENATOR WIENER, CHAIR WAHAB,
MEMBERS OF THE SUB FIVE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR BECKER FOR
THE ALLOCATIONS FOR THE RIGHT
GRANT FOR NONPROFITS PROVIDING
PROGRAMING IN CDCR AND FOR
ENDING THE DEDUCTIONS FOR
CLOTHING AND TRANSPORTATION FOR
PEOPLE BEING RELEASED FROM CDCR.
THANK YOU. HELLO, MY NAME IS
LARA DIÆN. I'M WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND, WE WANTED TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT $9.9
MILLION BE REINSTATED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT, SO THAT
WE CAN SEE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB 1137 THAT WAS PASSED INTO
LAW. NOW, TWO YEARS AGO, OIL
DRILLING IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
NIGHTMARE. IT POLLUTES THE
SOURCE OF LIFE. OUR AIR AND OUR
WATER AND THE STATE LEGISLATURE
VOTED TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES BY
CREATING THESE PUBLIC SAFETY
BUFFER ZONES. TWO YEARS AGO, AN
ENORMOUS EFFORTS HAVE GONE INTO
DEFENDING THAT THOSE PROTECTIONS
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS. AND SO
NOW BLOCKING IMPLEMENTATION BY
NOT FUNDING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LAW WOULD BE A FAILURE TO
PROTECT OUR AIR AND OUR WATER
AND A FAILURE OF DEMOCRACY AS
WELL. SO WE URGE YOU TO SEE IF
THIS CAN BE REINSTATED. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
STATE'S ONGOING WORK TO PREVENT
THEFT OF FOOD AND CASH BENEFITS.
WE ALSO ASK YOU TO CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE CONSISTENT ACCESS TO
BENEFITS DURING THE TRANSITION
TO EBT CHIP TAP TRANSACTIONS TO
KEEP FAMILIES FED, WHILE WE WORK
TO ENSURE THAT THE NEW CARDS
WILL WORK. WE'RE ALSO EXCITED
ABOUT THE NEW THE STATE PURSUING
THE TANF PILOTS, WHICH PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TRULY
REIMAGINE CALWORKS AS A FAMILY
CENTERED PROGRAM BY LIMITING
SANCTIONS, ENSURING CRITICAL
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES LIKE CHILD
CARE, AND EMPOWERING FAMILIES TO
DETERMINE THEIR PATHWAYS OUT OF
POVERTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. CHRISTINA SCARINGE
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY STRONGLY OPPOSING
DELAYS OR DEFUNDING OF SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION, COMMUNITIES
WORKED FOR OVER A DECADE TO GAIN
THESE PROTECTIONS. AND WHEN THE
AGENCY FAILED THEM, LOOKED TO
THE LEGISLATURE. SB 1137 WAS IN
PART TO PUSH THE AGENCY FOR ITS
FAILURE TO ACT ON ITS EXISTING
AUTHORITY TO ADDRESS OIL
POLLUTION NEAR HOMES AND
SCHOOLS. AFTER THAT HARD WON
BATTLE, THE OIL INDUSTRY SPENT
MILLIONS TO BUY AN 18 MONTH
DELAY WITH ITS RECENTLY
SURRENDERED VETO REFERENDUM. WE
WERE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT AB
157 WAS AMENDED OVER THE WEEKEND
TO ELIMINATE FUNDING FOR SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET. THIS DELAY IMPOSES
ANOTHER INEXPLICABLE YEAR
WITHOUT ACTION FOR COMMUNITIES
WHO'VE ALREADY WAITED TOO LONG.
THIS NEEDLESS DELAY IS A GIFT TO
INDUSTRY, A DERELICTION OF STATE
DUTIES, AND AN AFFRONT TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. IMPLEMENT
THE SETBACKS LAW. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. I AM
THE PRINCE OF TIME. I OPERATE A
SYSTEMS TASK FORCE WITH THE 28TH
CHIEF JUSTICE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
HONORABLE TANI CANTIL-SAKAUYE. I
AM NOW THE HIGHEST AUTHORITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, ABOVE
GAVIN NEWSOM. WHAT? I WILL BE
DOING WITH THIS AUTHORITY. I
WILL BE ESTABLISHING THE VALUE
OF TIME OR ESTABLISHING
UNIVERSAL HUMAN RIGHTS. AND I
WILL BE TRANSFORMING CDCR. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS, KENDRA HARRIS, THE
CLIMATE CENTER. I'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
ALSO HERE TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE 9.9 MILLION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137 BE
REINSTATED TO THE FINAL BUDGET
DEAL. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH AARON
READING ASSOCIATES, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS, UAW IN
SUPPORT OF AB 181, WHICH
CONTAINS THEIR MOU AND REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS TIM
MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS. AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB 177, WHICH IS THE HEALTH
CARE BUDGET BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, MALIK
BYNUM, ON BEHALF OF UAW, ACM AND
SEIU CALIFORNIA IN PARTNERSHIP
AS CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED,
I APPRECIATE THE HEARING THIS
MORNING. I WANT TO JUST EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE AND THANK YOUR
EXTREMELY HARD WORKING TEAM FOR
THE SHARP ATTENTION TO CHILD
CARE IN THESE FINAL TRAILER BILL
DISCUSSIONS. WE'RE ALWAYS
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH TOGETHER AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED WORK IN
THE SPACE, STARTING WITH RATE
REFORM. AND AS WE ENTER OUR
NEGOTIATIONS FOR OUR THIRD
CONTRACT THIS YEAR. SO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, TERRY MCHALE, WITH
AARON REED AND ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL
2881. IN SUPPORT OF THE MOU.
THAT'S BEFORE YOU. THE TWO MOST
INTERESTING PARTS OF THIS CAL
FIRE WILL GO FROM A 72 HOUR
WORKWEEK TO A 66 HOUR WORKWEEK.
STILL MEANS THEY WILL WORK TEN
HOURS MORE THAN LOCAL ENTITIES,
BUT IT IS A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND SECOND OF ALL,
WHEN THIS CONTRACT IS OVER, OUR
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS WILL BE
MAKING AS MUCH AS THOSE WHO ARE
WORKING AT MCDONALD'S RIGHT NOW.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AARON REED,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMEN, THAT MAKES THREE OF
OUR CLIENTS THAT SETTLED THIS
YEAR. THEY'RE THE ONLY THREE
THAT WERE AT THE TABLE THIS
YEAR. ALL THREE SETTLED, SETTLED
EARLY. SO YOUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LA COULD HAVE
ADEQUATE TIME TO EVALUATE THEM.
WE APPRECIATE THE HELP OF YOUR
STAFF AND EVERYBODY INVOLVED. I
WILL SAY THIS. THE CHP CONTRACT
PROBABLY ISN'T ENOUGH TO SOLVE
OUR RECRUITMENT PROBLEM. THEY
HAVE 1000 VACANCIES ACTUALLY
OVER 1000 VACANCIES, AND WE
STRUGGLE TO FILL IT. THE SAME IS
TRUE FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO WE'RE NOT ALONE. SO THE POOL
IS SHRUNK AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT JUST WOULD RATHER
NOT BE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. THESE
DAYS. SO THIS CONTRACT WILL HELP
A LITTLE BIT, I HOPE. BUT WE'LL
REPORT BACK TO YOU AND SEE HOW
WE'RE DOING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
SONYA HARRIS. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF IMAGINATION LIBRARY
OF CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE
REGRETFULLY, IN OPPOSITION OF
SECTION 84, SPECIFICALLY OF AB
157. IT TAKES $68 MILLION OF
TAXPAYER MONEY AND SENDS IT TO A
TENNESSEE BASED ORGANIZATION
WITH LIMITED OVERSIGHT BY YOU
ALL, AS WELL AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SINCE THE BOARD WAS
ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR, WE'VE HAD
GREAT SUCCESS IN TERMS OF
APPOINTING BOARD MEMBERS,
SELECTING AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR,
AND REALLY BEGINNING TO WORK
WITH THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
WE'VE GOT 35 OF 58 COUNTIES
ONLINE IN SOME WAY, WHETHER
THAT'S FULL OR PARTIAL COVERAGE
AND WORKING TO GET THOSE ONES
WITH PARTIAL COVERAGE ALL THE
WAY UP TO COVER ALL THOSE ZIP
CODES AND REALLY WORKING WITH
THAT LAST 23. ONE OF THE
GREATEST RATE LIMITING FACTORS
FOR OUR LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS IS
THE 1 TO 1 MATCH THAT THE
PROGRAM REQUIRES. SO A LOT OF
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE BEEN
HAVING WITH THESE PARTNERS HAS
REALLY BEEN AROUND. HOW DO WE
HELP YOU WITH SOME OF THAT
FUNDRAISING AND REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE WE'VE GOT THE DIVERSE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA IN MIND.
SO AGAIN, PLEASE, THE SECTION 84
WILL ONLY FURTHER DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND AGAIN,
ELIMINATE CALIFORNIA'S
OVERSIGHT. THANK YOU. HI, JOHN
BENTON WITH CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF FIRST
LIFE CALIFORNIA, ECHOING THE
CONCERNS OF MISS HARRIS
REGARDING SECTION 84, IN SB, AB
157, REMOVING THE MONIES FROM
CALIFORNIA AND SENDING THEM TO
TENNESSEE JUST MAKES NO SENSE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS
JOINED COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB 157,
PARTICULARLY SECTION 84 AND ITS
LIMITED OVERSIGHT, OF A LARGE
CALIFORNIA MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT, ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
IS WE FEEL THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
BASED IN CALIFORNIA, THAT
ORGANIZATION, WE SHOULD HAVE WE
DO HAVE AN ORGANIZATION THAT
DOES IT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
IT WAS OUR OWN CALIFORNIA BASED
IMAGINATION LIBRARY OF
CALIFORNIA, STRONG LEADERSHIP
PARTNERSHIP THAT PROMPTED THE
NATIONAL PROGRAM OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF BILINGUAL SPANISH
PROGRAM, WHICH HAD NOT HAPPENED
IN OTHER STATES. OUR FAMILIES
NEED A CALIFORNIA BASED
OVERSIGHT OF THIS PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE'S DIVERSE
NEEDS ARE CONSIDERED. AS WE
CONTINUE TO HELP NURTURE THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. TYLER, EARL. WITH
COMMUNITIES FOR BETTER
ENVIRONMENT RESPECTFULLY ASKING
THE COMMITTEE TO REINSTATE $9.9
MILLION FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
1137 CBE REPRESENTS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
INCLUDING WILMINGTON, LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
CONTAINS HUNDREDS OF OIL WELLS
NEAR HOMES. WILMINGTON RESIDENTS
ARE AMONG THE 2 MILLION PLUS
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE EXPOSED TO
THE TOXIC EMISSIONS FROM THE
ROUGHLY 30,000 OIL WELLS WITHIN
3200FT OF HOMES, SCHOOLS AND
OTHER SENSITIVE SITES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. SB 1137, WHEN PASSED,
WAS TO LEAD THE COUNTRY IN
HEALTH PROTECTIONS FROM OIL
DRILLING, BUT WITHOUT ACTUAL
FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION. WE
FAIL IN OUR CLIMATE LEADERSHIP
AND WE FAIL THE COMMUNITIES WHO
FOUGHT HARD FOR THIS LANDMARK
LAW. THE RESEARCH IS CLEAR
DRILLING WITHIN 3200FT OF HOMES,
DAYCARE CENTERS AND SCHOOLS IS
DANGEROUS. PLEASE REINSTATE THE
9.9 MILLION FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB 1137. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS KAYLA KARIMI
AND I'M WITH THE CENTER ON RACE,
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THE 9.9
MILLION BE REINSTATED FOR SB
1137 IMPLEMENTATION. CRP HAS
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE OF
NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING, OIL
DRILLING FOR DECADES. OUR
ORGANIZATION SPONSORED THE
ORIGINAL SETBACK BILL, AB 345,
IN 2019 WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND SB 467 WITH YOU,
SENATOR WIENER Ã. BILL CRP WAS
PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR FROM THE
START THE FIGHT TO GET A HEALTH
PROTECTIVE BUFFER ZONE WAS AN
UPHILL BATTLE. WE WERE TOLD TO
WAIT FOR A STUDY AFTER STUDY TO
SHOW WHAT OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
LONG KNOWN. FOR GENERATIONS,
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
FACED HARMFUL THREATS IN THEIR
OWN BACKYARDS. CRP COMMUNITIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE TWO
LONG GRUNTED THE HARM OF THE
ABSENCE OF A BILL LIKE SB 1137,
THEY HAVE BEEN LIVING AND
WORKING NEAR IDLE WELLS, ACTIVE
WELLS, AND THEIR HEALTH HAS BEEN
SUFFERING. WE ARE NOT
EXAGGERATING WHEN WE SAY SB 1137
WILL SAVE LIVES. WHAT WE ARE
FIGHTING FOR WASN'T NEW. IN
FACT, OTHER OIL PRODUCING
JURISDICTIONS, INCLUDING TEXAS
AND LOUISIANA, ALREADY REQUIRE
OIL COMPANIES TO HAVE SETBACKS
TO KEEP NEW OIL WELLS A SAFE
DISTANCE FROM PEOPLE. DELAYING
FUNDING ONLY SETS THIS IMPORTANT
WORK BACK. PLEASE REINSTATE THE
9.9 MILLION FOR SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, EMMA SILBER WITH
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, LA. I WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES LIVING IN THE SHADOW
OF OIL DRILLING. WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT THE
$9.9 MILLION FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB 1137 BE REINSTATED INTO
THE FINAL BUDGET BILL. PSR LÀ
UNITES THE CREDIBLE VOICES OF
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES IMPACTED
BY NEIGHBORHOOD OIL DRILLING.
NEIGHBORHOOD OIL DRILLING IS
FUNDAMENTALLY INCOMPATIBLE WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE PRACTICE OF
OIL EXTRACTION, WHICH INVOLVES
INJECTION TRANSPORTATION AND
STORAGE, PRODUCES TOXIC
CHEMICALS THAT POLLUTE OUR AIR
AND SOIL. MANY OF THESE
CHEMICALS ARE CARCINOGENIC,
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTING CHEMICALS
THAT CAUSE FERTILITY ISSUES OR
CAUSE RESPIRATORY HARM. THESE
CHEMICALS, SUCH AS BENZENE,
PARTICULATE MATTER, AND
FORMALDEHYDE. RESIDENTS LIVING
NEAR DRILL SITES EXPERIENCE
HEADACHES, BURNING EYES AND
THROATS, INCREASED RESPIRATORY
ILLNESS, NAUSEA, AND HIGHER
CANCER MORTALITY, INCLUDING
INCREASED DIAGNOSES OF CHILDREN
WITH LEUKEMIA. THESE NEGATIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS ARE DOCUMENTED IN
NUMEROUS STUDIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, AND HAVE BEEN
CONFIRMED BY AN EXPERT PANEL
COMMISSIONED BY CAL JAM, THE
STATE REGULATOR. DELAYING
FUNDING FOR SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION ALLOWS THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS TO CONTINUE
UNCHECKED. FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
DESERVE IMMEDIATE ACTION AFTER
FIGHTING TO PROTECT THEIR HEALTH
FOR DECADES. PLEASE REINSTATE
THE $9.9 MILLION FOR SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MABEL SANG AND I SERVE
AS THE POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE $9.9
MILLION FOR SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION BE REINSTATED
INTO THE FINAL BUDGET DEAL AFTER
SB 1137 WAS PASSED IN 2022 WITH
THE DELAY. WITHIN DAYS, OIL
INDUSTRY BEGAN COLLECTING
SIGNATURES TO CHALLENGE MAJOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NGUYEN,
FORCING OVER 500 PERMITS TO
DRILL, PROFITING OFF OF THE
HEALTH OF COMMUNITIES OF COLOR,
STAFF MEMBERS AND THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
CAME TOGETHER TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST BIG OIL TO PROTEST. TO
PROTECT THIS LAW, WE WORKED WITH
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TO CALM THE URGENCY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO SUPPORT TO KEEP
THIS LAW AND IMPLEMENT SB 1137.
WE BUILT A CAMPAIGN THAT
INTIMIDATED THE OIL INDUSTRY TO
ABANDON THEIR CAMPAIGN MONTHS
EARLY BEFORE REACHING THE
BALLOT. WHEN THE REFERENDUM WAS
WITHDRAWN, SB 1137 WENT INTO
EFFECT THIS YEAR, JUNE 28TH. OUR
COMMUNITY CELEBRATED THIS HARD
FOUGHT WIN AND WE ARE FINALLY
READY TO BEGIN THE HARD WORK.
HARD WORK TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. NOW THAT BIG OIL IS
NO LONGER STANDING IN THE WAY OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS. HOWEVER,
WITHOUT FUNDING THE GOVERNOR AND
NOW YOU, THE LEGISLATURE, ARE
DOING THE WORK OF BIG OIL. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS TASK IS
COMPLICATED AND COMPLICATED, BUT
OUR MEMBERS ARE READY TO PARTNER
WITH THE LEGISLATURE,
ADMINISTRATION AGENCIES TO BEGIN
THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB 1137. HOWEVER, WITH DELAYING
FUNDING FOR SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION WILL NOT MAKE THE
TASK BEFORE US ANY EASIER. THE
GOVERNOR NOW YOU THE
LEGISLATURE, ARE ASKING
COMMUNITIES TO CONTINUE TO WAIT
FOR HEALTH PROTECTIONS.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES DESERVE
THESE BASIC HEALTH PROTECTIONS
DECADES AGO. PLEASE REINSTATE
THE 9.9 MILLION FOR SB 1137.
ASHA SHARMA, ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND,
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT THE
9.9 MILLION FOR SB 1137
IMPLEMENTATION BE REINSTATED
INTO THE BUDGET DEAL, WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE VOICES
SHARED BEFORE ME, AND
COMMUNITIES HAVE SPENT DECADES
FIGHTING FOR THE SCIENCE BACKED
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION AND
DELAYING FUNDING, HOWEVER,
INADVERTENTLY HANDS BIG OIL
ANOTHER WIN IN THIS FIGHT.
PLEASE REINSTATE THE 9.9 MILLION
FOR SB 1137 IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. I'M RAQUEL MASON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
I'M ALIGNING MY COMMENTS WITH
ALL THE SPEAKERS BEFORE US ABOUT
SB 1137 IMPLEMENTATION. PLEASE
REINSTATE THAT FUNDING. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO REGISTER CLIMATE ACTION
CALIFORNIA SISTERS OF SAINT
JOSEPH'S OF ORANGE AND CALPIRG.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GABRIELA FAZIO WITH
SIERRA CLUB, CALIFORNIA. I'M
HERE TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
1137, AND THE 9.9 MILLION BE
REINSTATED BACK INTO THE FINAL
BUDGET DEAL. AS OTHERS HAVE
ALREADY STATED, THIS IS DECADES
OF WORK COLLECTION DATA
COLLECTION OF DIRECT IMPACTS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH, DECADES OF
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES FIGHTING
FOR THESE BASELINE PROTECTIONS
FROM NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING. THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT ANY
LONGER. I URGE YOU TO REINSTATE
THE 9.9 MILLION BACK INTO THE
BUDGET DEAL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS VANESSA
OROZCO, AND ON BEHALF OF GOLDEN
STATE OPPORTUNITY AND THE ITC
COALITION, WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE FOR RESTORING 2
MILLION OF FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT, EDUCATION AND OUTREACH,
AND FREE TAX PREPARATION
SERVICES. THIS FUNDING WILL
GREATLY BENEFIT HARDWORKING
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE LOWEST
INCOMES, ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
GETTING THE TAX RELIEF THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO AND CAN FILE
THEIR TAXES AT NO COST. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR LAURA SOLORIO AND
I AM PRESIDENT OF PROTECT
MONTEREY COUNTY. I PRACTICE IN
SALINAS AT THE COUNTY HOSPITAL
FOR 30 YEARS. JUST THIS YEAR,
CAL JAM RELEASED ITS FINAL
PUBLIC HEALTH REPORT, WHICH
SHOWED DEFINITIVELY THE CLOSER
HOMES ARE TO OIL AND GAS WELLS,
THE GREATER LIKELIHOOD OF
ADVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES SUCH AS
ASTHMA, OTHER RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES, PRETERM BIRTHS, RISK,
HIGH RISK PREGNANCIES AND
INCREASED CANCER RISK. THIS IS
OUR OWN AGENCIES INFORMATION.
PLEASE REINSTATE THE $9.9
MILLION BACK INTO THE BUDGET AND
IMPLEMENT SB 1137. WE ARE PAYING
THE HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
COSTS EVERY DAY. PEOPLE ARE
SICK. WE'RE FIGHTING FIRES,
FLOODS. PAJARO IS IN MY
DISTRICT, YOU KNOW, WE'RE PAYING
FOR IT ONE WAY OR ANOTHER. SO IF
WE COULD JUST IMPLEMENT THIS AND
KIND OF GET A HANDLE ON THIS,
IT'D BE GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. KATIE MCCAMMON WITH 350
SACRAMENTO. I'M RESPECTFULLY,
REITERATING WHAT ALL THE GREAT
PEOPLE WHO CAME IN FRONT OF ME
ARE SAYING, AND I'M SURE A LOT
MORE ARE GOING TO SAY, PLEASE,
WE'RE GOING TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT 9.9 MILLION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137 BE
REINSTATED IN THE FINAL BUDGET
DEAL. OVER 2.7 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITHIN 3200FT
OF AN OPERATIONAL OIL AND GAS
WELL, AND 69% ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
FOUGHT FOR DECADES FOR BASIC
PROTECTION FROM NEIGHBORHOOD
DRILLING. THERE IS NO REASON TO
MAKE THEM WAIT LONGER. REMOVING
THIS FUNDING WILL PROVIDE THE
OIL INDUSTRY WITH THE DELAYS
THEY WANT AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. PLEASE REINSTATE
THE 9.9 MILLION BACK INTO THE
BUDGET DEAL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK,
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THE 9.9
MILLION BE REINSTATED FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137 INTO
THE FINAL BUDGET NEGOTIATION IN
WILMINGTON AND CARSON. OUR
MEMBERS LIVE NEAR OIL DRILLING
SITES IN THEIR LOCAL PARKS, IN
ADDITION TO MASSIVE REFINERIES
THAT ALSO PERIMETER THEIR AREAS.
THEY ARE AMONGST THE 2.7 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT LIVE WITHIN
3200FT OF AN OPERATIONAL OIL AND
GAS WELL, ALMOST 70% OF WHICH
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR. REMOVING
THIS FUNDING CONTINUES TO DELAY
AS DESIRED BY THE OIL INDUSTRY
AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. PLEASE REINSTATE
THE 9.9 MILLION FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS NICOLE GIL.
I'M WITH FRIENDS OF THE EARTH.
WE ARE THE LARGEST GRASSROOTS
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK IN THE
WORLD, WITH OVER 2 MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES, INCLUDING
MEMBERS LIKE ME HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ECHOING THE
VOICES BEFORE ME, I'M HERE TO
URGE YOU TO REINSTATE THE $9.9
MILLION FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
1137. YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM
MANY REPRESENTATIVES FROM
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY NEIGHBORHOOD
DRILLING IN CALIFORNIA, BUT 2.7
MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITHIN
3200FT OF OPERATIONAL OIL AND
GAS WELLS. 69% OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR. THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE FOUGHT FOR
BASIC PROTECTIONS FROM
NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE, AND THEY SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO WAIT A MINUTE LONGER
FOR THESE PROTECTIONS. REMOVING
FUNDING CONTINUES TO GIVE THE
OIL INDUSTRY THE DELAYS IT WANTS
AT THE EXPENSE OF IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
PLEASE REINSTATE THE $9.9
MILLION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND SENATORS.
ROSANNA CARVACHO ELLIOT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM, I'M GOING
TO MIX IT UP FOR A MINUTE HERE
AND TALK ABOUT CHILD CARE. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S QUICK RESPONSE
WHEN THEY HEARD ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
FACING IN THE CHILD CARE FIELD,
WITH SOME NEW BUILDING
REGULATIONS ABOUT FIRE
INSPECTIONS THAT IS PREVENTING
US FROM OPENING NEW CHILDCARE
FACILITIES, AS WELL AS
TRANSITIONING TO SERVE INFANTS
AND TODDLERS FROM OLDER AGE
GROUPS. SO, AGAIN, APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S QUICK RESPONSE.
AND SO OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 176, THE EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS GREG SPOONER AND I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH SCIENTIST
REBELLION, A CLIMATE JUSTICE
GROUP. AND I'M A PHYSICIAN,
SORRY, A PHYSICIST MYSELF. AND I
WANTED TO MAKE IT PERSONAL FOR
YOU BECAUSE I JUST STOOD IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS OF SIGNAL HILL,
CALIFORNIA, AND LONG BEACH,
CALIFORNIA, WITH OTHER
SCIENTISTS AND LOCAL ACTIVISTS.
AND I SAW THE OIL WELLS BEING
DRILLED DOWN THERE, NEW OIL
WELLS BEING DRILLED DOWN THERE,
AND I COULD SEE JUST HOW CLOSE
THOSE WELLS WERE TO PEOPLE'S
BACKYARDS. AND I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE YOU FEEL PERSONALLY HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS. SO PLEASE,
WITH WITH ALL THE OTHER CITIZENS
HERE URGING YOU TO REINSTATE THE
$9.9 MILLION IN THE FINAL BUDGET
BILL TO IMPLEMENT SB 1137, THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
ZACH LU, AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW DEAL
COALITION. WE'RE JOINING THE
CHORUS OF ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THE
REINSTATEMENT OF $9.9 MILLION
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
1137. AS PEOPLE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT, THIS WAS A LANDMARK BILL
THAT WAS FOUGHT FOR MANY YEARS
BY OUR COMMUNITIES AND BY MANY
OF YOU ALL FOR URGENTLY NEEDED
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS
FOR MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS,
CALIFORNIANS THAT LIVE WITHIN
3200FT OF OIL AND GAS WELLS.
CUTTING THIS FUNDING NOW
CONTRADICTS THE STATED GOAL OF
GETTING STAFFING AND RESOURCES
IN PLACE TO CARRY OUT THE LAW,
AND WE KNOW FURTHER DELAYS WILL
COME AT THE CONTINUED EXPENSE OF
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. PLEASE
REINSTATE THE $9.9 MILLION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION BACK INTO THE
BUDGET AND ACT URGENTLY TO MAKE
THIS LANDMARK LAW A REALITY.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ADRIA
OKORO AND I AM THE SENIOR
COUNSEL OF PUBLIC POLICY FOR
UNITED WAY, CALIFORNIA CAPITOL
REGION HERE. ALSO ALIGNING
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO REMOVE SECTION 84
OF SB 157 AND TRANSFERRING $68
MILLION TO AN OUT OF STATE
ENTITY, UNITED WAY. CALIFORNIA
CAPITAL REGION, IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH DOLLY PARTON, HAS
DISTRIBUTED OVER 3000 BOOKS TO
PEOPLE OF ALL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
PROPER OVERSIGHT. WHY WOULD WE
SEND $5 MILLION WITH IN ADVANCE
TO AN OUT-OF-STATE ENTITY? WE
REALLY NEED TO THINK AND BE
MINDFUL OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE CENTER
EQUITY, AND WE HAVE AN ENTITY
THAT CAN SUPPORT EQUITY. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
AARON NIEMELA WITH NEMOPALPUS,
ON BEHALF OF A CAMPAIGN, THE
CAMPAIGN FOR A SAFE AND HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA. WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR HAVING THE
FORESIGHT TO FUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137.
SENATOR GONZALEZ'S SETBACK LAW.
BUT WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THIS WEEKEND TO REMOVE THE
FUNDING AS PART OF WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND WAS A THREE PARTY
DEAL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. PAMELA
GIBBS, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. FIRST OF ALL, I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR THANKS AND
GRATITUDE FOR EVERYTHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE THIS
YEAR RELATED TO HEAD START,
EARLY LEARNING AND CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS. SPECIFICALLY, I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR THANKS FOR THE
PROVISIONS IN AB 176 TO ALLOW
ENROLLMENT FOR TWO YEAR OLDS IN
THE PROGRAM, AND THAT IS OF
COURSE, A PRIORITY FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AS WE SERVE OVER 8000,
NEARLY 9000 HEAD START AND EARLY
LEARNERS. SO THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT. WE KNOW AN EARLY
START IS AN IMPORTANT START. SO
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ALSO, I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS CHILD CARE SPEAKER
RELATED TO THE FIRE SAFETY
PROVISIONS. WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MOVING QUICKLY
ON THAT AS WELL. AND URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO, MY NAME IS MIRIAM. I'M
WITH FOSSIL FREE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M HERE TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE $9.9 MILLION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF 11 SB 1137 BE
REINSTATED INTO THE FINAL BUDGET
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ZOE JANEK. I'M THE LEAD
ORGANIZER WITH 350 BAY AREA, AND
I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AMENDMENTS TO AB 157 THAT WOULD
REMOVE FUNDING FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137, AS
THIS IS A BILL THAT CANNOT BE
DELAYED ANY FURTHER, AS THERE
ARE LIVES AND HEALTH ON THE
LINE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CAMILLE DELA CRUZ. I AM A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH OIL AND
GAS ACTION NETWORK TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT SB
1137 FUNDING BE REINSTATED BACK
INTO THE FINAL BUDGET DEAL.
OGWEN REPRESENTS AND SUPPORTS
CLIMATE, GRASSROOTS MOVEMENTS
AND FIGHTING FOR A SUSTAINABLE
AND LIVABLE FUTURE FOR ALL. IT
IS UNCONSCIONABLE THAT ANY
COMMUNITY AND MAJORITY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO LIVE NEXT
TO AND BREATHE IN HARMFUL
TOXINS. AFTER DECADES OF
FIGHTING FOR BASIC PROTECTIONS
FROM NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING,
PLEASE SHOW US YOU CAN
PRIORITIZE PEOPLE AND PLANET
OVER PROFIT AND REINSTATE THE
$9.9 MILLION FOR IMPLEMENTATION
BACK INTO THE FINAL BUDGET DEAL.
THANK YOU. HI. EXCUSE ME, I AM
ZACH NORRIS. I AM THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE DIRECTOR WITH
GREENPEACE. ALIGNING MY COMMENTS
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
$9.9 MILLION BE REINSTATED.
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA HAS
SUED THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY
FOR DECADES OF LIES AND
DECEPTION, AND THEY CONTINUE TO
THWART AND DELAY COMMON SENSE
REGULATION. COMMUNITIES CANNOT
WAIT A MOMENT LONGER. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MELISSA ROMERO
WITH CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS HERE TO AGAIN, WITH ALL
THE OTHERS WHO HAVE DONE SO,
URGE YOU TO REINSTATE THE 9.9
MILLION ALLOCATED FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137 INTO
THE FINAL BUDGET DEAL. IF WE DO
NOT FUND MEASURES LIKE THESE
NOW, WE WILL SEE ESCALATING
HEALTH CARE COSTS DUE TO
INCREASED HEALTH ISSUES LINKED
TO OIL AND GAS DRILLING. THE
REMOVAL OF THIS FUNDING ONLY
BENEFITS THE OIL INDUSTRY BY
FURTHER ENABLING DELAYS AND
NEGLECT OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. SO PLEASE REINSTATE
THIS FUNDING OUR COMMUNITIES
CANNOT AFFORD TO WAIT ANY LONGER.
WE URGE YOU TO HAVE THE
POLITICAL WILL TO ACT
DECISIVELY. I WAS ALSO ASKED TO
VOICE THIS POSITION BY THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. EARTH JUSTICE AND
CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA AS
WELL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, JAMIE PUGH
WITH NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA HERE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
FUNDING FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB 1137 BE RESTORED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET. THE COMMUNITIES
THAT LIVE NEAR THESE WELLS
DESERVE TO BREATHE CLEAN AIR, TO
GIVE IN TO THE OIL INDUSTRY'S
DEMANDS FOR DELAY IN A LAST
MINUTE BUDGET DEAL, TWO YEARS
AFTER THIS BILL WAS PASSED, IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE INJUSTICE
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
FACED FOR YEARS. FOR DECADES.
PLEASE REINSTATE FUNDING FOR
THIS LAW. THANK YOU. HI, I'M
ALAN HIRSCH. I REPRESENT THE
RAC, THE RELIGIOUS ACTION CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE 99
CONGREGATIONS WITH 148,000
MEMBERS. WE ASK THAT SB 137
FUNDING BE RESTORED. SB 3137 IS
ONE OF IS ABOUT ONE OF JUDAISM'S
CORE VALUES. TACOMA SHALOM,
WHICH IS IN HEBREW, IS LITERALLY
HEALING THE WORLD. IN THIS CASE,
137 IS ABOUT LITERALLY HEALING
THE WORLD, PUNCTURED BY OIL
WELLS, OIL WELLS THAT ARE
POLLUTING THE AIR NEAR SCHOOLS
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
THESE OIL WELLS ARE GASSING OFF
HIGH IMPACT GREENHOUSE GASES
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND MANY OF YOU CAME
ACROSS THE YOLO CAUSEWAY THIS
MORNING THAT IS BEING WIDENED.
IT WILL TAKE CALTRANS ESTIMATE
THAT WILL TAKE A DRILLING 100
OVER 100 NEW OIL WELLS TO FUEL
THE CARS DRIVING ACROSS THAT
FREEWAY. THE PEOPLE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BENEFIT
FROM CHEAPENING THE REPAIR OF
THE OIL WELLS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE REFUND. ONE
137 THANK YOU. HI, JASON PFEIFLE
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. I'M ECHOING THE
COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY MADE URGING
YOU TO REINSTATE THE $9.9
MILLION FOR FUNDING
IMPLEMENTATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
LANDMARK HEALTH BUFFER LAW, SB
1137. THANK YOU. GREG LUCAS,
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARIAN,
JOINING WITH SOME OF THE
SPEAKERS YOU HEARD EARLIER IN
OPPOSITION TO SECTION 84 OF AB
157. THAT'S MY RECOLLECTION.
STATE LIBRARIES WORKED WITH THE
GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
EXPAND THE IMAGINATION AND
IMAGINATION LIBRARY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PAST TWO
YEARS. YOU'VE HEARD THE PROGRESS
THAT'S BEEN MADE, I'M TELLING
YOU WHAT YOU KNOW ALREADY.
CALIFORNIA ISN'T LIKE ANY PLACE
ELSE WHERE THE MOST DIVERSE
GROUP OF PEOPLE BROUGHT TOGETHER
AS EQUALS IN THE HISTORY OF
HUMAN CIVILIZATION. èC SAYS
THERE'S 200 TO 260 LANGUAGES AND
DIALECTS SPOKEN HERE. WE HAVE A
POPULATION HIGHER THAN 159. OF
THE 195 COUNTRIES ON THIS
PLANET. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS GOVERNED BY
CALIFORNIA, GOVERNED BY
CALIFORNIANS SECONDARILY, AS A
GRANT MAKING ENTITY CONCERNS ME
THAT WE WOULD WRITE A CHECK OF
UPWARDS OF $68 MILLION TO A
NONPROFIT, NO MATTER HOW
VIRTUOUS THEIR GOALS ARE. IN
ANOTHER STATE, WHERE THERE'S NO
RECOURSE IN CASE SOMETHING
HAPPENS THAT WE DON'T LIKE THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL BEGINS
WITH, NOTWITHSTANDING ANY OTHER
SECTION IN LAW, WHICH MEANS ALL
OF THE TRANSPARENCIES AND ALL OF
THE ACCOUNTABILITIES THAT WE
SUBJECT EVERY OTHER GRANTEE AT
THE STATE LIBRARY TO ARE ABSENT
IN THIS CASE. AND I DON'T
THERE'S NO JUSTIFICATION IN THE
BILL FOR THIS CHANGE IN POLICY.
BUT IF THE JUSTICE IF THE INTENT
IS TO SPEED UP PUTTING MORE
BOOKS INTO THE HANDS OF KIDS,
THIS ISN'T GOING TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT. AND WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY,
YOU KNOW, URGE YOU TO REMOVE
THAT LANGUAGE FROM THE BILL AND
LET THE PROGRAM CONTINUE TO WORK
AS IT'S WORKING NOW. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. HELLO. MY NAME IS
ANDREW MELENDEZ. I'M A LIFELONG
RICHMOND RESIDENT, AND I'M HERE
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
9.9 MILLION FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137 BE
REINSTATED INTO THE FINAL BUDGET
DEAL, AS A YOUTH GROWING UP IN
RICHMOND, I'VE LIVED MY ENTIRE
LIFE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THE
LOCAL CHEVRON REFINERY, WHICH
HAS POLLUTED THE AIRWAYS OF MY
COMMUNITY AND THREATENED THE
WELL-BEING OF THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF RICHMOND RESIDENTS
WHO OVER THE LAST DECADES HAVE
FACED INCREASED CHRONIC NEGATIVE
IMPACTS LIKE ASTHMA AND CANCER.
CUTTING THIS FUNDING NOW WILL
ONLY DELAY THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE TO HOLD POLLUTERS
ACCOUNTABLE, AND WILL ONLY ALLOW
BIG OIL COMPANIES TO CONTINUE TO
EXPLOIT LOW INCOME BIPOC
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE AND MANY
OTHERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IN A
TIME OF HEIGHTENED CONCERN OVER
THE CLIMATE CRISIS. IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER BEFORE
TO MAKE THIS ADDRESS AND MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. I HOPE THAT IN
MAKING YOUR DECISIONS OVER THIS
BUDGET, YOU KEEP INTO
CONSIDERATION THE GENERATIONS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE ACTIONS
THAT YOU MAKE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI. I JUST WANT TO
START OUT BY THANKING THE
MEMBERS AND CHAIRPEOPLE OF THIS
BODY FOR TAKING TIME TO LISTEN
TO OUR STATEMENTS. MY NAME IS
KENDALL JOHNSON. I WORK WITH THE
RICHMOND PROGRESSIVE ALLIANCE AS
WELL AS THE RICHMOND SHORE,
SHORELINE ALLIANCE, AND I WOULD
LIKE TO URGE EACH OF YOU TO STOP
THE AMENDMENT OF SB 1137 AND
REQUEST THAT THE $9.9 MILLION OF
IMPLEMENTATION IS SUPPORTED, YOU
KNOW, OVER 2.6, 2.7 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITHIN A
3200FT OF OPERATIONAL OIL AND
GAS WELLS, 69 OF THOSE, 69% OF
THOSE FOLKS ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THE HEALTH AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS
THAT AFFECT THESE COMMUNITIES
LAST GENERATIONS. AND SO TENS OF
GENERATIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
AFFECTED BY THESE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS. AND THOSE WILL AFFECT
THEIR CHILDREN AND THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN. SO TO ECHO WHAT
MY YOUTH COUNTERPART MENTIONED,
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
FOUGHT MANY YEARS FOR BASIC
PROTECTIONS FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
DRILLING RIGHTS AND EVEN WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE $9.9
MILLION, THEY WILL STILL BE A
LOT MORE NEED TO SUPPORT AND
REBUILD THESE COMMUNITIES. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND PLEASE,
PLEASE REINSTATE THE 9.9 MILLION
BACK TO THE BUDGET MEAL DEAL.
THANK YOU. BUENOS DIAS. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS SAUL RUIZ,
PRESIDENTE DEL COMITÉ DE LOS
KILLED IN ACTION. MY NAME IS
SAUL FROM LOS HILLS IS THE C¯
APOYAN LA SIETE DECIR SI A ESA
LEY PORQUE MI COMUNIDAD HA SIDO
MUY ASOCIADA POR LOS CAMPOS DE
PETROLEO. I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SB 1137 AS MY COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN IN ATTACK BY THE OIL
INDUSTRY, IS THE LA ESCUELA DE
LOS CAMPOS DE PETROLEO UN CUARTO
DE MILLA Y LOS NINOS NO APRENDEN
TIENEN C¯. ESTAR BATALLANDO LOS
NINOS Y LOS MAESTROS CON LOS
NINOS. PORQUE LOS NINOS NO
APRENDEN POR EL MALO. LA C¯ HAY
EN LA ESCUELA EN LOS CEOS, A
SCHOOL IN LOS HILLS IS ONLY A
QUARTER OF A MILE AWAY FROM AN
OIL FIELD. AND THIS DISTURBS THE
EDUCATION OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE ODOR AND THE
IMPACTS OF OIL DRILLING. TENGO
MUCHO TIEMPO PIDIENDO LÀ A Kò A
LOS LEGISLADORES Y A TODOS QUÊ
APOYAN LOS VILLAS Y C¯ APOYAN LA
COMUNIDAD DE LOS WILK ES MUY
ASATADA POR LOS CAMPOS DE
PETROLEO. I'VE BEEN HERE MANY
TIMES TO ASK LEGISLATORS TO
SUPPORT LOS HILLS AND PROTECTING
THE COMMUNITY FROM THE IMPACTS
OF OIL DRILLING. THE NUMBER IS
Â MALA MUCHAS ENFERMEDADES COMO
CANCER, ASTHMA, PROBLEMAS DE LOS
PULMONES CON LAS FAMILIAS. SI
USTEDES QUIEREN PUEDEN MIRAR EN
EL CONDADO DE KERN EN LOS
HOSPITALES DEL CANCER, COMO
ESTAN Y DE QUÉ PARTE DE LA
COMUNIDADES ES DONDE HAY MAS
PACIENTES, SINO ES DE LOS OJOS.
OUR COMMUNITY OF LOS HILLS HAS
BEEN IMPACTED BOTH IN ODOR AND
ILLNESS, WITH HIGH RATES OF
ASTHMA AND CANCER. YOU CAN GO
LOOK IN KERN COUNTY, THE RATES
OF CANCER IN BOTH LOS HILLS AND
BAKERSFIELD. QUÉ TAN GASTANDO
PARA LAS COMPANIAS DE PETROLEOS?
LAS LAS GASTON IN IN HOSPITALS
QUÊ QUÊ NECESITAN C¯ HAY MUCHOS
ENFERMOS. YEAH, THE MONEY SPENT
ON THE OIL INDUSTRY SHOULD
INSTEAD BE USED FOR HOSPITALS
AND TO CARE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SICK, POR FAVOR. QUÉ USTEDES
TIENEN EN SUS MANOS? EL VOTO LO
HAGAN. POR QUÉ HAY COMUNIDADES
COMO LA MIA C¯ ESTAN MUY
ASOCIADAS A CAUSA DE LOS CAMPOS
DE PETROLEO. YO NO ESTOY EN
CONTRA DE C¯ BUSCAN PETROLEO. YO
ESTOY EN CONTRA DEL DANNO. QUÉ
LE TAN HACIENDO LAS COMUNIDADES.
MUCHAS GRACIAS. AND FOR YOU WHO
HAVE THE POWER TO HAVE A VOTE
TODAY TO HELP THE OUR
COMMUNITIES, I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT US. AND, I'M NOT AGAINST
OIL DRILLING. I'M JUST AGAINST
THE HEALTH IMPACTS THAT IT HAS
ON MY COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. AND
IF IT'S OKAY, I'M DOING A
SEPARATE COMMENT. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS IVAN ORTIZ WITH THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK, AND I'M HERE TO
ASK YOU TO, IMPLEMENT THE TO
APPROVE THE $9.9 MILLION FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137 AS A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER, COUNTLESS
OF TIMES I'VE HEARD STORIES FROM
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND MÀ IN
ARVIN OF, OF CASES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY OF CANCER, OF KIDS WHO
HAVE LEUKEMIA DUE TO THEM LIVING
DOWN THE STREET FROM AN OIL, OIL
REFINERY, PERSONALLY, I'VE BEEN
WITNESS OF LEAKING OIL WELLS AND
OIL TANKS THAT ARE RIGHT BEHIND
A CLINIC, AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THIS BILL TO BE SUPPORTED
BECAUSE THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
FACED THESE NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITIES FOR WAY TOO LONG.
AND, I FEEL IF WE WAIT TOO LONG
FOR, THESE PROTECTIONS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED, THE COST OF LIFE
AND THE COST OF HEALTH CARE
WOULD BE TOO GREAT. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS ELENA NAVARRO
WITH THE COMMUNITY. I AM A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK. I AM ALSO HERE
WITH THE RESIDENTS FROM LOST
HILLS AND RESIDENTS FROM
BUTTONWILLOW, THESE SMALL
FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES CANNOT
CONTINUE TO BE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED BY OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DRILLING. WE
HAVE TRAVELED HERE TODAY TO ASK
YOU TO REINSTATE THE FUNDING FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 1137.
FOUR MORE YEARS CAN BE SUPER
DETRIMENTAL FOR HEALTH IMPACTS
OF THESE COMMUNITIES AND THESE
ARE ALREADY OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES. AS THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTER MENTIONED WE NEEDED.
1137 NOW, THANK YOU. HELLO, MY
NAME IS CHELSEA YOUNG. I'M A
PHYSICIAN HERE REPRESENTING
CLIMATE HEALTH. NOW A GROUP OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
ADVOCATING FOR CLIMATE HEALTH
POLICY IN CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
9.9 MILLION FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB 1137 BE REINSTATED INTO
THE FINAL BUDGET DEAL. WE ARE
ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE NEGATIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH
LIVING NEAR OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DRILLING,
WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
COUNTLESS CASES OF RESPIRATORY
DISEASE, NEURODEVELOPMENTAL
DISEASE, AND NEURODEGENERATIVE
DISEASES, AMONG MANY OTHER
HEALTH ISSUES WHICH HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS,
COULD BE PREVENTED BY TIMELY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE FUNDS.
PLEASE PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. I'M REBECCA WENT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY AND AS A LIBRARIAN AS
BOTH AS AND SOMEONE WHO WORKS
DIRECTLY WITH OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS. I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU
INFORMATION BECAUSE LIBRARIANS
ARE INTO INFORMATION, AND I'M
SPEAKING RELEVANT TO ASSEMBLY
BILL 157, SPECIFICALLY SECTION
84, THAT IS, SPEAKING ABOUT THE
IMAGINATION LIBRARY. THE
IMAGINATION LIBRARY IS AN
AMAZING PROGRAM THAT GIVES FREE
BOOKS TO CHILDREN. 0 TO 5
THROUGHOUT THE PARTICIPATING
AREAS WITHIN THE STATE AND
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE HAD THIS
PROGRAM FOR A WHILE, AND BECAUSE
THERE IS ALREADY A CALIFORNIA
ITERATION OF THE IMAGINATION
LIBRARY, I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF WE
RESTART THIS WITH THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S IN THE BILL TODAY. THIS
WOULD RESTART EFFORTS, DELAYING
THE IMPLEMENTATION. WE ALREADY
HAVE BOOTS ON THE GROUND AS WE
HAVE HEARD FROM SPEAKERS TODAY,
AND THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN MAKING
SURE THAT THE COMMUNITIES ARE
ABLE TO SUSTAIN A PROGRAM. WE
DON'T WANT THE PROGRAM TO GO
AWAY WHEN THE INITIAL SEED MONEY
DISAPPEARS. THIS IS NOT GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA KIDS AND WE DON'T
WANT THE OLDER BROTHERS AND
SISTERS TO GET THE BOOKS AND THE
LITTLE ONES TO BE ALL EXCITED
AND THEN NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE A
PROGRAM FOR THEM. SO IN THE
INSTANCE OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS SUSTAINABLE WITH
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE IN CHARGE, IT
MAKES MUCH MORE SENSE NOT TO
SEND THE MONEY DIRECTLY TO
TENNESSEE. OF COURSE, AT THE
STATE LIBRARY, WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY, AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE SUSTAINABILITY
COMPONENT WOULD BE A BIG PART OF
THAT. SO IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO
CONTINUE ON THE ROAD THAT WE'RE
GOING DOWN. WE HAVE THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND. WE HAVE PEOPLE
INTERESTED IN A SUSTAINABLE
PROGRAM. AND THE EFFORTS OF TWO
YEARS HAVE BEEN GOING INTO THIS
PROGRAM ALREADY. I JUST WANTED
TO LET YOU KNOW THIS LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL MAKES THAT ALL A MOOT
EFFORT, AND IT DOESN'T MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE. SO AS A LIBRARIAN,
I'M HOPING THAT YOU GOT THE
INFORMATION YOU NEEDED TODAY.
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSEN, AND ON BEHALF OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION, THE PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE, THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER, AS
WELL AS THE SACRAMENTO AREA
CONGREGATIONS TOGETHER AND ALL
TO SEE, HEADED BY FORMER CAL EPA
SECRETARY TERRY TAMMINEN. WE'RE
URGING THE RESTORATION OF THE
$9.9 MILLION. WE THINK THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. ALSO,
WE'RE URGING THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD ON CONTINUED SUSTAINABLE
BLUE ECONOMY MEASURES, WHICH ARE
GOING TO BE SO IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY TO OUR HEALTH BUT TO THE
ECONOMY OF THE STATE AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS GREG HERNER ON
BEHALF OF MILLER INDUSTRIES,
HERE TO TALK ABOUT A QUICK, VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM CALLED THE
FREEWAY SERVICE PATROL. IT
AFFECTS EVERY ONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS. IT PROVIDES 700,000
ASSISTS TO MOTORISTS ANNUALLY,
FREE ASSISTS TO MOTORISTS
ANNUALLY. WE HAVE A SERIOUS
PROBLEM WITH THE CARB RULE UNDER
THE ADVANCED CLEAN TRUCKS AND
OMNIBUS. MANY OF YOU HEARD ABOUT
THIS BAY AREA METRO HAS REACHED
OUT TO EVERY MEMBER IN THEIR
DISTRICT THAT THEY SERVE THE
NINE COUNTY REGION. THERE ARE 16
FREEWAY SERVICE PATROLS IN THE
STATE FROM RIVERSIDE, SAN
BERNARDINO, SAN DIEGO, MARIN,
SACRAMENTO, EL DORADO, PLACER,
FRESNO. YOU'RE ALL AFFECTED.
YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE ALL
AFFECTED. AND THE REASON BAY
AREA METRO REACHED OUT IS
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
UC BERKELEY HAS DOCUMENTED TO
SAVE OVER 18 MILLION GALLONS OF
FUEL ANNUALLY, OVER 10,000,000
HOURS OF MOTORISTS SITTING IN
TRAFFIC ANNUALLY, OVER
164,000,000KG OF CO2 REDUCTIONS
ANNUALLY. THE STATE HAS ALREADY
FUNDED THIS BECAUSE IT HAS A
COST BENEFIT RATIO OF $7 OF
BENEFITS FOR EVERY DOLLAR THE
STATE INVESTS. WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW, THOUGH, IS THAT CARB CAN'T
FIX THIS REGULATION FAST ENOUGH.
SO MEMBERS SUCH AS SENATOR
BECKER, SENATOR ASHBY, SENATOR
CABALLERO, SENATOR RUBIO AND
SENATOR UMBERG WHO HAVE
FACILITIES IN THEIR DISTRICT
THAT MANUFACTURE NEW TOW TRUCKS
FOR THIS PROGRAM, ARE GOING TO
GO OUT OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE
END OF THE YEAR, AND WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE FROM 250 TO 500
DIRECT JOBS AT THESE FACILITIES.
IF WE DON'T PUT IN A QUICK FIX
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE TRUCKS
CAN BE MADE AND MANUFACTURED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE FREEWAY
SERVICE PATROL. SO WE'RE URGING
YOU TO ADOPT AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T LOSE THESE JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THESE GREAT PROGRAMS
FOR THE CITIZENS AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG. AND
ALSO, I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER THE OPPOSITION OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION BOTH TO THE REMOVAL
OF IMPLEMENTATION FOR SB 1137
FUNDING. YOU ALL HAVE HEARD FROM
THE MANY, MANY PEOPLE HERE WHO
IS NOT EVEN EVERYONE OF ALL OF
THE GROUPS THAT ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS. WHEN I THINK
ABOUT CUTTING THAT FUNDING, I
THINK ABOUT NAYELI COBO, WHO IS
NOW A 23 YEAR OLD ACTIVIST. SHE
STARTED AT THE AGE OF NINE WITH
HER MOTHER FIGHTING AGAINST THE
OIL WELL THAT WAS 30FT FROM HER
HOME. THAT CAUSED HER TO HAVE
HEADACHES, NOSEBLEEDS, STOMACH
ACHES. SHE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER AS A RESULT OF THE
EXPOSURE AT THE AGE OF 19, HAS
HAD THREE SURGERIES AND STILL
SUFFERS HEALTH EFFECTS FROM
THAT, AND HAS REALLY DEVOTED HER
LIFE AS AN ACTIVIST TO TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT OTHER CHILDREN
DON'T SUFFER THE SAME HEALTH
PROBLEMS THAT SHE HAS. YOU ALL
KNOW THE HISTORY OF THIS BILL.
HUGE, LONG FIGHT, GETTING IT
PASSED AND THEN TWO YEARS WHERE
THE REFERENDUM PREVENTED IT FROM
BEING IMPLEMENTED AND IT JUST
FEELS TRAGIC TO NOT FUND
IMPLEMENTATION. AND SO I URGE
YOU NOT TO DO SO. THANK YOU.
GREAT. ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT?
OKAY. WE WILL NOW CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. COLLEAGUES. SENATOR
CUEVAS, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND I JUST HAD A QUESTION. JUST
LISTENING TO ALL OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND REALIZE THAT THIS IS
INFORMATION THAT, AS A MEMBER, I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO REALLY WRAP
MY HEAD AROUND. IS THERE MORE
THAN WHAT WE RECEIVED ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS ON THE
RETAIL CRIME BILL PACKAGE IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE ACTUAL COSTS
ARE, I THINK THE GENERAL
FRAMEWORK WAS THAT THE COSTS
WERE UNKNOWN BUT SUBSTANTIVE.
BUT THERE WASN'T AN ACTUAL
DOLLAR FIGURE. I'M CURIOUS, WHAT
IS THE COST OF THE TOTAL
PACKAGE? AND HOW CAN WE GET THAT
INFORMATION? YES. THE WHAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE SETS OF TRAILER
BILLS ARE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
BUDGET ACT. SO I'LL HAVE TO GET
YOU THAT TOTAL NUMBER, AFTER THE
HEARING. YEAH, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT, WE KNOW THAT
INCARCERATION AND IN THIS
STATE'S EXPERIENCE WITH MASS
INCARCERATION IS DEEPLY
EXTRACTIVE. AND IMPACTS OUR
ABILITY TO DO THE WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO KEEP COMMUNITIES
SAFE AND, IT ALSO CREATES
OBSTACLES WHEN WE ARE BUILDING
PIPELINES INTO PRISON FOR
NONVIOLENT PROPERTY CRIME,
BASICALLY, CRIMES OF POVERTY,
AND WE'RE NOT INVESTING IN
BUILDING PATHWAYS FOR THE SAME
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES INTO
QUALITY JOBS. AND CAREERS. FOR
EXAMPLE, YOU KNOW, THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS MAKING IN OUR
CLIMATE RESILIENT ECONOMY,
CALIFORNIA IS EXPECTED TO
RECEIVE $100 BILLION. BUT WE
AREN'T BUILDING PATHWAYS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE FRONT AND CENTER IN THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. SO IT WOULD BE
GOOD TO SEE WHAT THE OVERALL
COSTS NOW THAT WE ARE ON THE
HOOK FOR AS A STATE AROUND THESE
BILLS AND WHAT ARE THE IMPACTS
IT WILL HAVE ON OUR ABILITY TO,
CREATE, NOT EXTRACTIVE, BUT
CONTRIBUTORY PATHWAYS THAT HELP
US MOVE OUR FOLKS OUT OF POVERTY
AND IN THOSE SITUATIONS OF THESE
NONVIOLENT CRIMES. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO BETTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR,
I'LL ALSO NOTE FOR THE RECORD
THAT THERE HAS BEEN AN ANALYSIS
ABOUT A PENDING BALLOT MEASURE
THAT COULD ADD BILLIONS TO THE
BUDGET AS WELL. SO IT'S AN
IMPORTANT THING TO BE MINDFUL
OF. AND I APPRECIATE YOU RAISING
THE ISSUE, SENATOR CORTEZ. YEAH.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF. I JUST WANT TO,
ESSENTIALLY ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF SENATOR
BARRASSO EARLIER, WHEN SHE WAS
QUESTIONING THE LACK OF LABOR
STANDARDS, INEQUITY. YOU KNOW,
THUS FAR, AND I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS QUITE AWARE OF
WHAT THE POSITION IS OF SEVERAL
OF US THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THAT FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW.
SO I DON'T WANT TO YOU KNOW, GO
ON AND ON ABOUT IT WHEN WE'VE
WE'VE GOT DOCUMENTS AND LETTERS
AND, THE ORIGINAL BASIS OF SB
150, BUT, BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
INDEPENDENTLY, EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF US THAT'S BEEN WORKING ON
THE ISSUE IN THE SENATE, AT
LEAST IN THE SENATE, HAVE HEARD
FROM CONSULTANTS, AND AGENCY
PERSONNEL AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY'RE REALLY
TAKEN ABACK BY THE FACT THAT,
WHAT THEY ASSUMED WOULD BE THE
CASE, WHAT THEY WOULD ASSUME BE
WOULD BE THE CASE, AND THAT
THAT'S ALMOST THE EXACT WORDS OF
THE LAST FEDERAL CONSULTANT I
SPOKE TO, THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD
WOULD HAVE EQUAL OR GREATER
LABOR AND EQUITY STANDARDS THAN
WHAT WAS PUT INTO THE TWO
STIMULUS ACTS, WHICH WAS JUST,
EXTRAORDINARILY SURPRISING. AND
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE TALKING TO
PEOPLE LIKE THAT FACE TO FACE TO
SEE THE REACTION TO SEE THE BODY
LANGUAGE, SO I THINK, AGAIN,
I'LL STOP THERE, BUT I JUST I
DIDN'T WANT. SENATOR DEROSA TO
BE OUT THERE ALONE OR ON THAT
ISSUE OR MAKING REPRESENTATIONS
THAT THERE'S A CONCERN ABOUT
MISALIGNMENT OR MISALIGNMENT OR
JUST LACK OF ALIGNMENT WITH WITH
WHAT OUR OWN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS TRYING TO GET US TO DO ON
THAT, ON THAT TOPIC, BECAUSE
THAT'S DEFINITELY BEEN CONFIRMED
BY OTHERS OF US. AND WE HOPE
THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE ISSUE, YOU KNOW, GOING
FORWARD, THAT IT WILL MAKE A
BREAKTHROUGH HERE. I KNOW WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GIVE UP ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS. SENATOR
BURR AND THEN SENATOR BARRASSO.
YES. I JUST WANTED TO ASK FOR A
RESPONSE ABOUT, THE DELAYS THAT
ARE PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION BEING LONGER THAN
WHAT WOULD BE EXPECTED GIVEN THE
REFERENDUM AND SUBSEQUENT
WITHDRAWAL OF THE REFERENDUM. SO
CAN WE CAN CAN WE JUST HAVE A
RESPONSE? THERE WERE MANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS, AND I'D
LIKE TO AFFILIATE MYSELF WITH A
LOT OF THE PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
JUST ASK FOR AN UNDERSTANDING OF
IT. GOOD MORNING, STEVEN BENSON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
SO THE TIMELINE CHANGES REFLECT
A REVIEW OF THE REALISTIC AND
CURRENT TIMELINE NECESSARY TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS
OF 1137, BASED ON THOSE WHO HAVE
TO ACTUALLY CARRY OUT THE WORK.
SO WHAT HAPPENED IS, DURING THE
PERIOD OF TIME OF REFERENDUM,
THERE WAS A REVIEW AS A PROPOSED
PREPARED PROPOSALS TO IMPLEMENT
THE BILL THAT WENT THROUGH AND
LOOKED AT EVERYTHING THAT HAD TO
GET DONE AND WHAT WAS GOING TO
BE NECESSARY TO DO THAT. AND THE
PROPOSED TIMELINE CHANGES
REFLECT WHAT THOSE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL INDICATE
AS NECESSARY TO GET ALL OF THAT
WORK DONE APPROPRIATELY. OKAY.
THANK YOU. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THIS BE DONE. SO
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD MY
COMMENTS TO THE, TO PRIORITIZING
THIS WHEN WE ARE DECIDING ON OUR
STATE BUDGET AND ALSO HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION PRIORITIZE IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BARRASSO. THANK YOU, ALONG THOSE
LINES, BUT RELATED TO IT, IF YOU
COULD REMIND ME IN TERMS OF THE
PLANS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
SUBMITTED, IS THERE A SPACE IN
THOSE PLANS FOR A SOCIOECONOMIC
YOU KNOW, IMPACT IN THE
COMMUNITIES? I COULD BE LIKE,
THIS MAY BE NOT THE RIGHT PLACE
FOR IT, BUT, SINCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT, THE OIL INDUSTRY AND THE
COMMUNITY, I JUST WANT TO KNOW,
IS THERE CONNECTED TO THIS OR
HOW IS CONNECTED TO IT? IS THE
SOCIOECONOMIC IMPACT? JUST TO
CLARIFY, YOU'RE IN REGARDS TO
THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE FOR
SB 1137. YEAH. I'M, I'M, I DON'T
REMEMBER ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
SAY YES, BUT IF IT'S THERE OR IS
IT WHERE WHERE IS THAT SPACE TO
GET A SOCIOECONOMIC, IMPACT? I
DON'T THINK THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL ITSELF DELINEATE
SOCIOECONOMIC SORT OF VALUATION.
IT'S MORE AN EVALUATION OF THE
ACTUAL CONTAMINANTS THAT ARE
COMING OUT AND WHAT STANDARDS
NEED TO BE MET IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THOSE THINGS GET PLUGGED
AND THE LEAKS PREVENTED. AND SO
I THINK THAT SORT OF BROADER
THAN JUST THE SOCIOECONOMIC
IMPACTS, I THINK THE IDEA IS
THAT THE CONTAMINANTS WILL BE
SHUT DOWN SORT OF ACROSS THE
BOARD. IS THE AIM AND THAT THAT
WOULD BE WHAT THE PLANS WOULD BE
SEEKING AT IS IDENTIFYING WHAT
METRICS HAVE TO BE MET AND WHAT
EQUIPMENT AND THINGS ARE
NECESSARY TO PROPERLY MONITOR
THOSE THINGS AND READ THE LEVELS
OF CONTAMINANTS IN THE AIR, SO
THAT THERE CAN BE A LIKE AN
ELIMINATION OF THEM. OKAY. SO
THAT INFORMATION THROUGH THIS
PROCESS IS NOT AVAILABLE. SO
PART OF THAT NEEDS TO WELL, MOST
OF THAT NEEDS TO BE DEVELOPED BY
THE AIR BOARD AS A PART OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED BY
SB 1137. AND THAT'S ACTUALLY A
BIG PART OF WHY THE TIME THAT WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT IS
NECESSARY IS THERE'S SUBSTANTIAL
RESEARCH AND TESTING AND
MONITORING THAT HAS TO GET DONE
IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY AND
ESTABLISH THE STANDARDS THAT
NEED TO BE IN REGULATION IN
ORDER TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THOSE
PLANS. OKAY. THANK YOU. REAL
QUICK, SENATOR WAHAB FOLLOWED BY
OR SENATOR SALAZAR FIRST, THEN
SENATOR WAHAB BOB. SO JUST
FOLLOWING UP A LITTLE BIT ON
THAT, THE ISSUE ISN'T MANPOWER
AT CAL JAM. IT'S STUDIES THAT
NEED TO BE DONE BY AIR RESOURCES
BOARD THAT'S HANGING THIS UP. SO
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDED POSITIONS
AT CAL JAM, THE AIR BOARD AND
THE WATER BOARD. SO ACTUALLY THE
AMOUNT THAT'S BEEN CITED TODAY
OF 9.9 MILLION ISN'T ACTUALLY
ISN'T ACTUALLY CORRECT. THE
PROPOSAL WAS 14.9 MILLION. THE
9.9 MILLION IS THE PART THAT'S
SPECIFIC TO CARB BUT OR SORRY,
SPECIFIC TO CALCIUM. BUT THERE
WAS ALSO 2.2 MILLION SPECIFIC TO
CARB AND 2.6 MILLION SPECIFIC TO
THE WATER BOARD. AND A LOT OF
THE INITIAL UPFRONT WORK NEEDS
TO BE COMPLETED BY CARB BECAUSE
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT REGULATORY
WORK THAT HAS TO GET DONE IN
ORDER TO IMPLEMENT THE LEAK
DETECTION AND ACTION AND
RESPONSE PLANS. DOESN'T CAL CAL,
JIM HAVE LIKE 60 PEOPLE ASSIGNED
TO FRACKING? WE DON'T HAVE
FRACKING ANYMORE. SO WHERE IS
THERE DELAY IN GETTING PEOPLE UP
AND RUNNING TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS? SO AGAIN, THE MOST OF THE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO GET DONE TO
GET THIS UP IS CARB, NOT
CALCIUM. SO CALCIUM DOES HAVE
POSITIONS. THEY NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR SOME OF
THE NEW ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
RELATED TO THIS BILL. HOW MANY
POSITIONS DO THEY NEED? THEY
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE OVER THERE.
THEY'VE DOUBLED OR TRIPLED THE
SIZE OF CALCIUM IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, FEW YEARS HERE.
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES 37
POSITIONS FOR CALCIUM. DOES ANY
OF THOSE 37 POSITIONS, INCLUDE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THEY HAVE
ASSIGNED TO THE FRACKING UNIT?
THAT IS NOT DOING ANYTHING
ANYMORE. I DON'T BELIEVE THIS
INCLUDES A REDIRECTION OF THOSE.
I CAN CERTAINLY GO BACK AND LOOK
AT WHAT THOSE STAFF ARE BEING
REDIRECTED TO. THERE ARE IT JUST
SEEMS THAT MANPOWER SHOULDN'T BE
THE PROBLEM WITH CAL JAM, AND IT
SEEMS TO BE. AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR MORE POSITIONS AND MORE
MONEY FOR MORE POSITIONS WHEN WE
ALREADY HAVE POSITIONS. WE'RE
NOT EVEN USING. BUT IT DOESN'T
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE TO PEOPLE.
SORRY, SENATOR. A LOT OF IT IS
WITH CARB, THOUGH. THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE, I GET THAT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR WAHAB. FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR DALLI. THANK YOU. I'VE
SAID THAT A COUPLE OF TIMES
WHILE WE'VE BEEN HAVING THESE
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS, AND I DO
ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES HERE,
FROM AN ADMINISTRATIVE
STANDPOINT, AS WELL AS JUST THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE ARE
SPENDING AND CONTINUE TO SPEND
IN EACH OF THESE DEPARTMENTS. I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
OVERSIGHT, ACCOUNTABILITY, AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN AUDITING OF
EXACTLY WHAT ARE WE DOING? WHAT
ARE THE METRICS FOR SUCCESS? I
STILL DON'T SEE THAT IN ANY
DEPARTMENT, AND AT THE SAME
TIME, HOW DOES THAT TRANSLATE TO
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN? RIGHT. SO
I'M SAYING THIS NOW AND ON THE
RECORD JUST TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE SOME OF THOSE METRICS IN AS
WE'RE TALKING FOR NEXT YEAR AND
STARTING THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS
OF NOW, AS YOU GUYS ARE
PLANNING, MOVING IN FOR THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR, BUT THE REALITY IS,
FOR EXAMPLE, IN HEALTH, WE ARE
SPENDING BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
HEALTH. AND YET ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE COMPLAIN ALL
THE TIME ABOUT IS THEIR WAIT
TIMES, THE LACK OF, YOU KNOW,
SERVICE, THE DELAYS, THE, LACK
OF INFORMATION BEING, YOU KNOW,
PROPERLY HANDLED AND SO FORTH.
AND AT A CERTAIN POINT IN TIME,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SAY WITH
INVESTMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY, WITH
THE INVESTMENTS IN, YOU KNOW,
THE POSITIONS AND MUCH MORE,
WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO IMPROVE?
AND THAT HASN'T BEEN CLEARLY AND
I'VE STATED THIS, YOU KNOW,
MANY, MANY TIMES THAT HASN'T
BEEN CLEARLY SHOWN NOR SEEN, NOR
EXPERIENCED BY THE AVERAGE
RESIDENT. RIGHT. AND SO I'M ALL
FOR INVESTING IN NEW MEASURES,
NEW EFFORTS, NEW TECHNOLOGY, NEW
EVERYTHING, BUT UNLESS WE'RE
ABLE TO SAY THAT THESE ARE THE
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE USING FOR
THIS AND THIS IS THE OUTCOME AND
THIS IS THE IMPACT TO THE
AVERAGE PATIENT, TO THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENTS, TIMELINE WISE,
IMPLEMENTING NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
IT IS TAKING WAY TOO LONG ACROSS
THE BOARD IN ANY DEPARTMENT.
IT'S LIKE THE FACT THAT IT'S 3
TO 5 YEARS WHERE IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR, IT SHOULD BE ROUGHLY
ABOUT A YEAR, YEAR AND A HALF
MAX FOR FULL IMPLEMENTATION,
INCLUDING PARALLEL SERVICE. I
JUST CONSISTENTLY SEE THIS AS A
PROBLEM. WE ARE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE IN THE
WORLD, AND YET I WOULD STILL
ARGUE THAT THE NEEDS OF THE
AVERAGE RESIDENTS AREN'T BEING
SERVICED PROPERLY. RIGHT, I WILL
SAY HEALTH IS ONE OF MY BIGGEST
CONCERNS. PRIMARILY JUST BECAUSE
OF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT GOES
INTO IT. YOU KNOW, WE DID A LOT
OF REVAMPING RIGHT NOW IN THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT I OVERSEE FOR
THE MOST PART, AND THERE'S STILL
A LOT MORE WORK TO DO IN REGARDS
TO CUTTING BLOAT. THAT'S THE
HONEST TRUTH OF IT. NOBODY WANTS
TO SAY THAT WE ARE SPENDING A
LOT OF MONEY CONSISTENTLY
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING TAXES
IN EVERY SINGLE DEPARTMENT, OR
FEES OR THINGS LIKE THAT. WHEN
ARE WE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
BLOAT? AND GOVERNMENTS HAVE THIS
PROBLEM OF USING IT OR LOSING IT.
SO THEY WILL SAY THAT THEY'RE
SPENDING IT ON THIS OR THAT, BUT
IS IT FACTUALLY DONE? AND WHAT
IS THE BENEFIT OF CONTINUING TO
THROW MONEY AT A PROBLEM WITHOUT
A LEGITIMATE SOLUTION? AND I
WILL SAY THAT ACROSS THE BOARD,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THERE ARE
EFFORTS AND NEW IDEAS AND PEOPLE
WANT TO SAY THEY DID THIS AND
DID THAT, BUT WHAT IS THE
OUTCOME? SO I SAY THAT IN HOPES
OF HAVING A MORE DEFINED IDEA
AND PLAN FOR EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENT, SPECIFICALLY, THE
MOST BANG FOR OUR BUCK OF HOW
MUCH MONEY WE'RE SPENDING ON THE
LARGEST DEPARTMENTS AND BUDGET
SECTORS, BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE
SOME OF THE CHANGE MOVING
FORWARD NEXT YEAR. GENUINELY
RIGHT, AND MY OFFICE IS ALWAYS
HAPPY TO HELP. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT THE
PUBLIC DOES HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A LOT MORE WE CAN
DO. AND I AND I HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION TAKES THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY, BECAUSE AT A CERTAIN
POINT IN TIME, WHAT ARE WE DOING
IF THE AVERAGE RESIDENT IS STILL
UPSET ABOUT, YOU KNOW, HOW THEIR
HEALTH CARE IS BEING TREATED OR
THE FACT THAT IT KEEPS GOING UP
OR THE FACT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
INCREASE THEIR TAXES OR FEES OR
FOR WHAT? ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE
INVESTING IN TECHNOLOGY AND IT'S
SUPPOSED TO REDUCE EVERYTHING.
DOES THE WHOLE POINT OF
TECHNOLOGY IS TO MAKE THE COST
CHEAPER? RIGHT. SO I SAY THAT I
WILL MOVE AB 157 AND GET THE
SHOW ON THE ROAD. I HAVE ONE
MORE. OKAY. SENATOR DAWLEY, GLAD
YOU'RE DONE. NOW WE CAN MOVE ON.
I JUST WANT TO SAY FOR THE
RECORD, I SPENT FIVE YEARS ON
SUB TWO. OBVIOUSLY, WE HAD
COVID, BUT EVERY YEAR IN SUB
TWO, THE ADMINISTRATION ASKED
FOR MORE POSITIONS. AROUND 50
POSITIONS TO GO TO CAL CHEN. AND
I QUESTIONED THE FACT THAT WE
WEREN'T FILLING THE POSITIONS.
REALLY. WE KEPT ALLOCATING THOSE
POSITIONS, WHICH ARE PAID FOR BY
THE OIL INDUSTRY IN MANY CASES.
AND WE WERE GETTING LIKE 2 OR 3,
POSITIONS FILLED FOR THE 50 WE
ALLOCATED FOR FIVE YEARS. IT'S
BEEN THE SAME STORY. KALGAN
NEEDS AN AUDIT. WE NEED TO HAVE
AN AUDIT, FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE, BECAUSE WE
CONTINUE TO ADD POSITIONS. SOME
OF THOSE POSITIONS ARE GETTING
FILLED. SOME OF THEM ARE NOT
GETTING FILLED. SO IT WOULD BE
VERY WISE IN THE FUTURE TO DO AN
AUDIT OF COLLAGEN AND CARB, TO
SEE WHAT WE'RE GETTING FOR THOSE
POSITIONS, BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK THAT'S PUSHED BY
LEGISLATION TO THEM. BUT WE'RE
NOT GETTING THOSE POSITIONS
FILLED. SO I JUST WANT TO SAY ON
THE SUB TWO COMMITTEE, I SAT FOR
FIVE YEARS, WE HAVE PUT THE
MONEY UP TO FILL THOSE
POSITIONS. SOMETIMES WE COULDN'T
GET THE PEOPLE TO FILL THEM. THE
EXPERTISE WASN'T THERE. BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY, YOU CAN'T
EXPECT THEM TO GET IT DONE UNTIL
YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT.
FOR THE RECORD THAT IT'S NOT THE
ADMINISTRATION. IT'S NOT. IT'S
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO AUDIT IT AND
FIGURE OUT WHY WE CAN'T FILL
THOSE POSITIONS AND GET THE WORK
DONE. SENATOR DURAZO, YES. THANK
YOU. MY APOLOGIES. NO, THAT'S
THAT'S OKAY. I'M SORRY. I'M
GOING BACK AND FORTH, BUT SOME
OF THE THINGS JUST COME TO MIND,
AND WE'RE BEING ASKED TO VOTE ON
THIS TODAY. SO SOME OF THE
ANSWERS, MISS LEE, I KNOW ABOUT
GETTING BACK TO ME ON MY
QUESTIONS WILL PRETTY MUCH BE
TOO LATE, AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THIS ISSUE OF LABOR
STANDARDS FOR OUR TAXPAYER
INVESTMENTS IN THE ECONOMY IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME IN A NUMBER
OF, OF LEGISLATORS IS WHAT HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS LEAD TO GOOD PAYING
JOBS AND CAREERS? WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS NOW. WE HAD SB 150, WE'VE,
HAVE CLEAR, CLEAR DIRECTION FROM
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN
EXCHANGE FOR THEIR DOLLARS. AND,
IF I MAY, I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
IS THROUGH THE CHAIR OR THROUGH
MISS LEE. WOULD SEE IF MISS
CALVERT COULD COME. COME AND
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
AND, SENATOR DORADO, I DID WANT
TO GO BACK TO ONE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO THE
STANDARDS, THE STATE STANDARDS
VERSUS THE FEDERAL STANDARDS FOR
SOME OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
HAS COME DOWN. AND I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT FOR THE STATE FISCAL
RECOVERY FUND, THOSE DOLLARS
THAT CAME 27 BILLION FOR,
THROUGH ARPA, AT THAT POINT, THE
STATE STANDARDS WERE HIGHER THAN
THE FEDERAL STANDARDS IN REGARDS
TO CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. SO
THAT'S I KNOW THAT'S A SPECIFIC
SET OF FUNDS OUTSIDE OF THE IIJA
AND THE IRA, BUT IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR, YOUR COMMENT ABOUT TRYING
TO GET BACK INFORMATION TO YOU
TIMELY, AND I KNOW YOU HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION AS WELL, BUT
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY TO SENATOR
WAHAB THAT I ALSO WANTED TO
MENTION THAT OUR EFFICIENCIES
AND OUR VACANCY SWEEP, THAT WAS
PART OF OUR 24 BUDGET ACT ARE IN
PART, THEY'RE TAKING PLACE NOW.
WE'RE WORKING AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, IS WORKING WITH,
BUDGET, BUDGET DEPARTMENTS AND
OTHER OTHER, OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS IN REGARDS TO HOW TO
FIND SOME OF THAT, BLOAT AS YOU
SAY, SO THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE SOME
OF THE SAVINGS THAT WE, THAT
THAT IS INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
WE'RE, WE'RE HOPING TO WORK WITH
DEPARTMENTS ON AS WELL. I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I DO JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
BUDGET SAVINGS AND THE COST
SAVINGS FOR THE VACANCIES IS
VERY TEMPORARY. WE ALL KNOW THIS,
RIGHT. AND OFTENTIMES A LOT OF
DEPARTMENTS KEEP THE BUDGET OR
THE VACANCIES OPEN SO THEY CAN
USE THAT SALARY FOR SOMETHING
ELSE. SOME SMALLER PROJECT, THIS
IS A CONSISTENT STANDARD. BUT AT
A CERTAIN POINT I WOULD LIKE FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS,
YOU KNOW, EVERY HEAD OF EACH
DEPARTMENT TO TALK TO THE
SENATORS AS TO ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE CONCERNS WE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY WE HAVE THESE
MEETINGS. OF COURSE, IT HAPPENS.
YOU KNOW, THE BUDGET TAKES A
LONG TIME. LOTS OF CONVERSATION
INTERNALLY WITH WITHIN THE OAN,
YOU KNOW, SPECIFIC DEPARTMENTS.
BUT ALSO THE DIRECTION OF THE
SENATORS. WE ARE ALSO LIKE, FOR
EXAMPLE, EVERY SINGLE TIME WE'RE
ASKED ABOUT LABOR STANDARDS. SO
INSTEAD OF LIKE COMING BACK AND
SAYING, I'M GOING TO RESPOND
BACK, AS YOU KNOW, SENATOR
DURAZO, WAS TOLD IT'S THIS IS
OUR PLAN MOVING FORWARD. THIS IS
WHAT WE HAVE GOING FORWARD. THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING. SO BESIDES
VACANCIES AND COST SAVINGS FOR
VACANCIES, I'D LIKE TO SEE
BIGGER NUMBERS AS THESE WERE THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE DONE 30 YEARS
AGO. THEY'RE REALLY OBSOLETE.
THEY DON'T SERVE A REAL PURPOSE
IN TODAY'S TIME. WE NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AND ABSORB THE COST AND
SAYING AND SUGGESTING SEVERAL
PROGRAMS BE SHUT DOWN BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT IT'S EITHER
INTEGRATED OR WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ANOTHER PROGRAM
OR SOMETHING. THOSE TYPES OF
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY WELCOMED ON
MY BEHALF. RIGHT? BECAUSE AT A
CERTAIN POINT IN TIME, WE WE'RE
JUST FEEDING INTO A SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE NECESSARILY
SERVING THE MASSES. THE WAY THAT
IT SHOULD IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY OF THE WORLD. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, YES, MISS CALVERT,
GOOD TO GOOD TO SEE YOU. IF YOU
COULD, SINCE YOU'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN A LOT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS, IS THE CHANGES TO
STATE CONTRACTING AND
PROCUREMENT IN THIS TRAILER?
BILL, I'M ASKING IS HOW, DO OUR,
HOW DO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
GUIDANCE ON HIGHER STANDARDS
VERY HIGH STANDARDS THAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE INVESTING A QUARTER OF A
TRILLION DOLLARS INTO,
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MANY OTHER
WAYS OF INVESTING IN OUR
ECONOMY. BUT A VERY EXPLICIT
ABOUT THE KIND OF QUALITY JOBS.
SO HOW DO YOU HOW DID HOW DOES
THIS ADDRESS THAT HIGH PRIORITY
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AND FOR
THE DOLLARS THAT WE'RE GETTING?
THERESA CALVERT WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO I DON'T HAVE A
SATISFYING ANSWER FOR YOU RIGHT
NOW. WE ARE IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
EARLIER QUESTION, STILL LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS YOU
RAISED EARLIER IN THE HEARING
AND LOOKING AT THE FEDERAL FUNDS
AND ALSO THE CONTRACTING SIDE,
SO I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT A
NUMBER OF THE FEDERAL FUND
PROGRAMS ARE VERY DIFFERENT AND
ACROSS VERY DIFFERENT AREAS. SO
IT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT FOR
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AS TO WHAT
WHAT THE OUTCOMES OR THE
STANDARDS ARE RELATED TO, LIKE
THE HIGH QUALITY JOBS OR BETTER
PAYING JOBS. SO I DON'T HAVE A
GREAT, SATISFYING ANSWER FOR
YOU. RIGHT NOW. OKAY. I MEAN,
UNFORTUNATELY, AND I'LL JUST END
WITH THIS IS I'VE BEEN HEARING
THAT KIND OF RESPONSE FOR OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN. AND I
JUST IT'S JUST GETTING TO THE
POINT WHERE THERE'S NOTHING
WHAT'S SERIOUS ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, OF CARRYING OUT
THE THINGS THAT WE ALL SAY WE
WANT, PEOPLE DON'T WANT A
HANDOUT. THEY WANT A HAND UP,
THEY WANT A GOOD PAYING JOB, AND
WE HAVE IN OUR DISPOSAL BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT COULD BE USED TO
CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS SO
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO LINE UP,
YOU KNOW, AT A SOUP KITCHEN TO
BE ABLE TO GET A MEAL. I MEAN,
JUST ENOUGH IS ENOUGH WITH HOW
ARE WE SPENDING OUR DOLLARS AND
MAKING IT AVAILABLE IN A WAY
THAT BRINGS DIGNITY WITH IT? SO
THE END OF MY QUESTIONS, BUT I'M
JUST DISAPPOINTED THAT WE DON'T
HAVE MORE SPECIFIC ANSWERS HERE.
THANK YOU. AND I'M SORRY,
SENATOR, I DO HAVE A SOME
INFORMATION TO SHARE IN REGARDS
TO THE CAL JAM CONTRACTS.
ACCORDING TO CAL JAM, THEIR
CONTRACTS ADHERE TO THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS, WHICH ALSO INCLUDES
SKILLED AND TRADE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD START IN 2028. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR MR.
VICE CHAIR. AND THEN SENATOR
CUEVAS AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT I
SEE. AND THEN WE WOULD MOVE TO A
VOTE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
FIRST OF ALL, I'D LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE WITH THE COMMENTS OF
SENATOR WAHAB. I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN PUBLIC SECTOR
BUDGETS GOING BACK ABOUT 25
YEARS NOW. AND THE MANEUVERING
OF DEPARTMENTS, BUDGET
MANEUVERING OF DEPARTMENTS
THROUGH THE INTENTIONAL USE OF
VACANT POSITIONS IS AS OLD AS AT
LEAST THE TIME I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH PUBLIC SECTOR
BUDGETS, AND I'VE ALWAYS FOUND
IT SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATING. BUT,
ONE VACANCY THAT WE HAVE THAT
WAS MENTIONED TODAY IS REAL, AND
THAT IS WITH REGARD TO THE
HIGHWAY PATROL. A THOUSAND
POSITIONS UNFILLED AND THAT'S
NOT A BUDGET MANEUVER. IT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING A HARD
TIME HIRING PEOPLE AS OUR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT, AT LEAST
PARTIALLY DUE TO, PERCEPTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS THAT ARE
VERY UNFORTUNATE. BUT I HAVE
ALWAYS FELT AND I CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE WE HAVE FAR TOO MUCH CHP
PRESENCE HERE IN THIS LOCATION.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, OUR
GOVERNOR HAS, REDIRECTED THE
HIGHWAY PATROL. HIGHWAY PATROL
RESPONSIBLE FOR PATROLLING
SAFETY ON HIGHWAYS TO RETAIL
THEFT ACTIVITIES. I HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT IS CONTRARY TO THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL MISSION, AND THAT
CREATES ADDITIONAL VACANCIES. IN
FACT, WITH REGARD TO THE MISSION
OF CREATING SAFETY ON OUR
HIGHWAYS, WHICH IS DRASTICALLY
NEEDED. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR AND SENATOR CUEVAS,
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I JUST WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON SOMETHING THAT MISS
LEE MENTIONED AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION, THAT THE SKILL
AND TRAIN PROVISION APPLIES TO
CONSTRUCTION. I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
THE LABOR AND EQUITY STANDARDS
IN THE NEW ECONOMIES, WHICH IS
THE GREEN, THE MANUFACTURING
SPACE, THE THERE HAS BEEN WORK.
I THINK WE'VE HAD OVER SEVEN
FIELD HEARINGS, SIX OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS, TWO REPORTS, AND, A
STAKEHOLDER TABLE OF AGENCIES TO
AGENCIES ON THIS. AND THE
EVIDENCE IS PRETTY CLEAR IN
TERMS OF WHAT STANDARDS ARE
NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA AND HOW WE
NEED TO SET A UNIVERSAL LABOR
AND EQUITY STANDARD. I ALSO WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THE
BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN VERY CLEAR IN TERMS OF
GENDER EQUITY, EXECUTIVE ORDER,
A RACIAL EQUITY, EXECUTIVE
ORDER, A JOBS WITH JUSTICE
INITIATIVE AND TOOLKIT THAT
PROVIDES AND PRESCRIBES FOR
STATES WAYS TO ENSURE
COMPETITIVE EDGE BY HAVING SET
UNIVERSAL LABOR STANDARDS AND
MECHANISMS FOR BUILDING,
EQUITABLE WORKFORCE IN THE GREEN.
INVESTING IN AMERICA FUNDS. AND
YOU KNOW, THAT MEANS REALLY
ADDRESSING THOSE
UNDERREPRESENTED, DISADVANTAGED,
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN THOSE
IN THOSE JOBS. AND THIS I WANT
TO JUST REITERATE FROM SB 150,
TO THE WORK THAT MANY OF US ON
THIS DAIS HAVE HAVE WORKED
TOWARD, WE IN CALIFORNIA STILL
DON'T HAVE A COMPETITIVE EDGE.
WE DON'T HAVE A SET STANDARD
THAT DEALS WITH THE ISSUE OF
LABOR STANDARDS AND RACIAL
EQUITY, BASED ON ON ON SOME OF
THE FEEDBACK WE HEARD TODAY THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO BEST UTILIZE
THESE DOLLARS AND MULTIPLY THEM
IN OUR ECONOMY. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
INFORMATION THAT THAT YOU WILL
PROVIDE. BUT I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT I THINK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR,
ON THE GUIDELINES, BUT ALSO THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE THIS IS THE POINT THAT
WE'RE MAKING AS WE'RE HEARING
THAT WE ARE CUTTING THINGS OUT
OF THE BUDGET AS WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING, YOU KNOW, THESE
CRIME BILLS, WHICH ARE GOING TO
ADD SUBSTANTIAL, COST TO THE
STATE, WE SHOULD BE PREPARED TO
USE AND ACTIVATE THOSE FEDERAL
DOLLARS IN A WAY THAT CREATES
GOOD, HIGH QUALITY JOBS AND
CALLS IN OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. IT'S ABOUT A
BALANCED APPROACH. IT'S ABOUT
ENSURING THAT WE ARE, PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES WHILE WE'RE ALSO
HOLDING COMMUNITIES ACCOUNTABLE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
LAIRD, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
WAS SITTING HERE LISTENING TO A
LOT OF THE DEBATE, TRYING TO
MINE MY BETTER ANGELS TO NOT SAY
ANYTHING, BUT, I CANNOT I WAS IN
THOSE CHAIRS WHEN I WAS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. I REMEMBER BEING
IN A HEARING WHERE A MEMBER OF
THE ASSEMBLY SAID TO ME, WILL
YOU GUARANTEE THAT THE BUDGET
INCLUDES AND I THINK THREE TIMES
I HAD TO POLITELY SAY, WELL, YOU
ACTUALLY DO THE BUDGET. YOU'RE
THE ONE THAT HAS TO DECIDE IF
SOMETHING IS ACTUALLY IN THE
BUDGET. AND I THINK IN SOME OF
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAVE HAD
ABOUT OVERSIGHT, IT'S LIKE WE
ARE THE ONES THAT DO THE
OVERSIGHT. IT IS. WHEN I WAS
BUDGET CHAIR IN THE ASSEMBLY ONE
YEAR, WE WERE NOT GETTING WE HAD
100 REPORTS. WE WERE NOT GETTING
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION, AND I
BASICALLY SAID WE WOULD NOT
APPROVE A BUDGET WHERE A REPORT
WAS DUE OVERDUE UNTIL WE HAD THE
REPORT AND IT REMARKABLY LED TO
THOSE REPORTS BEING SUBMITTED.
SO IN THE BUDGET PROCESS, WE
COULD DO IT. AND I THINK LOOKING
TO THE ADMINISTRATION TO DO
OVERSIGHT ON ITSELF IS NOT THE
RIGHT PLACE. IT IS REALLY US
THAT THAT HAVE TO DO THAT AND US
THROUGH. WE HAD 15 SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN EDUCATION. WE WERE
REALLY ASKING WHAT THE RESULTS
WERE. WE WERE REALLY TRYING TO
TIE IT DOWN. AND I THINK THAT
WE'RE TO THE POINT THAT THE
BUDGET IN FRONT OF US IS MOSTLY
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS, AND WE
SHOULD APPROVE IT ALL. BUT WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING IS HAVING A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE AGENDA
IS FOR NEXT YEAR IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO OVERSIGHT ON THE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED,
MAKE SURE IF THERE ARE ANY
UNADDRESSED ISSUES, WHETHER IT
GETS BACK TO GOOD JOBS OR OTHER
THINGS, THAT THAT IS WHERE WE
START WHEN WE COME BACK NEXT
YEAR. AND, AND I THINK IT REALLY
IS INVOLVING US TAKING OUR OWN
POWER AND CONTROL AND DOING IT,
WHETHER IT'S OVERSIGHT OR
SETTING THOSE AGENDAS IN THE
BEGINNING, RATHER THAN FEELING
FRUSTRATED AT THE LAST HEARING
OF THE YEAR, THAT OVERSIGHT HAS
NOT BEEN DONE OR WE HAVE NOT
ADDRESSED THAT ISSUE. SO WITH
THAT, I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THE BUDGET BILLS IN
FRONT OF US. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR LAIRD. AND SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION, I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY ONE THING BEFORE WE
GO TO VOTES ON THE SETBACKS
ISSUE. AND I SAY THIS AS SOMEONE
WHICH WAS NOTED IN PUBLIC
COMMENT, I CARRIED ONE OF THE
ITERATIONS OF THE SETBACK BILL
AS PART OF THE GENERATION OF
GENERATIONAL MULTI GENERATION OF
AUTHORS WHO TRIED TO GET IT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
ULTIMATELY, THE GOVERNOR GOT
BEHIND IT AND WE WERE ABLE TO
GET IT PASSED. I, I WILL JUST
SAY, SPEAKING FOR MYSELF, THAT I
AM HIGHLY EAGER TO GET THAT LAW
IMPLEMENTED, THE, THE MONEY THAT
IS NOT IN THE BUDGET IS BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH,
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON THAT
ISSUE. AND SO WE NEED TO GET TO
AN AGREEMENT SO THAT THE FUNDING
CAN GO IN SO THAT WE CAN GET IT
DONE AND WE CAN PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM THE TOXIC
IMPACTS OF HAVING, OIL
PRODUCTION, OIL DRILLING NEAR
THEIR HOMES AND SCHOOLS. SO WITH
THAT, WE WILL MOVE TO VOTES AND
WE WILL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 157. I BELIEVE SENATOR
WAHAB ALREADY MOVED THAT BILL.
AND BEFORE WE START VOTING, DO
WE HAVE ANY INDICATION IF
SENATOR GROVE IS WE DON'T KNOW.
OKAY. SO WE'LL PUT STUFF ON.
WE'LL PUT EVERYTHING ON CALL, WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WAHAB
ON AB 157, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB 157. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATOR WIENER. AYE. WIENER AYE.
NILO. NØ. NILO NØ. BECKER AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR.
BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE. DOLLY NO. DOLLY. NO
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
GROVE. LAIRD. LAIRD I NEVER I
NEVER. AYE NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE PADILLA. AYE. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE CIERTO. CIERTO. NO.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WILK WILK. NO OKAY. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL. ITEM TWO AB
158. CAN I HAVE A MOTION, PLEASE?
SO MOVED MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
158. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
SENATORS WIENER. AYE. WIENER.
AYE NILO. NILO. NÓ. BECKER AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE
SPEAR. AYE. CORTEZ. CORTESI.
AYE. DOLLY DAWLEY. NO. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. GROVE
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN.
AYE PADILLA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
ROTH. AYE ROTH. AYE. SEYARTO
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHHAB. AYE WILK. NÓ. WILK. NO
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON
CALL, ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 176,
MOTION BY SENATOR LAIRD. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB 176. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. SENATORS
WIENER. AYE. WIENER. AYE MILO.
MILO. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
SHAKESPEARE. SHAKESPEARE. AYE.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. DALI DURAZZO
I. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. GROVE
LAIRD. HÌNH. LAIRD. AYE MENGIBAR
I MENGIBAR. AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN.
AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
ROTH. I. ROTH. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WILK.
AYE. WILK AYE. CAN. OH. IT'S
OKAY. WELCOME SENATOR. CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE OPPOSITE MEMBERS
ON ON ITEM THREE. AB 176. EGGMAN
GROVE. SKINNER. CIERTO OKAY,
WHAT IS THE. WHAT'S THE VOTE ON
THAT? CAN I HAVE A PEN? DO YOU
HAVE A PEN? THANK YOU. WHAT'S
THE VOTE ON THAT? 15 ZERO 1515
ZERO? OKAY, ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE, THE VOTE IS 15 TO 2. THAT
ITEM PASSES 15, ZERO. 15. I'M
SORRY. 15 TO 0. THAT ITEM
PASSES, LET'S GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE. PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. AB 157
SENATORS EGGMAN. GROVE. GROVE.
NO. ONE. WANT TO MAKE SURE I GOT
EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION HERE. 13.
FIVE. 13. FIVE. OKAY, THE VOTE
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE. AB 157 IS 13
TO 5. THAT ITEM PASSES. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM
TWO. AB 158 AB 158. SENATORS.
EGGMAN GROVE NØ GROVE NÓ. THREE
513. 13 FIVE. OKAY, THE VOTE IS
13 TO 5. THE ITEM PASSES. I WILL
GO TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB 177.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB 177.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS SEN
WIENER I WIENER I NILO. NILO I
BECKER I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. BLAKE SPEER I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE. DOLLY DOLLY I
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
GROVE. GROVE I LAIRD. LAIRD. I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I PADILLA I PADILLA I
ROTH A ROTH I CIERTO CIERTO I
SKINNER. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB I
WAHAB I WILK I WILK I 18 ZERO.
THAT VOTE IS 18 TO 0. THE ITEM
IS OUT. WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER. THAT WAS NUMBER FOUR
RIGHT. YES. GO TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB 178 AB 178. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS SENATOR DAHLE WIENER
I WIENER I MILO MOTION. SO
MOVED. OH, I'M SORRY. WE DIDN'T
GET A MOTION. 178 SO MOVED.
OKAY. ACTUALLY, ALISA. YES WE
DID. OKAY GREAT. YES. SORRY.
OKAY. MOVED BY SENATOR SKINNER,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SEN WIENER.
AYE. MILO. THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING ME. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER Ã. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. CORTEZ. CORTEZ AYE.
DOLLY DURAZZO I. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. GROVE. GROVE. AYE LAIRD.
LAIRD. I KNEW I MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. I PADILLA I
PADILLA, I ROTH. ROTH I CIERTO.
SKINNER I SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB I
WAHAB. AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE.
15 ZERO. OKAY. THE VOTE IS 15 TO
0. THE ITEM IS OUT, ITEM NUMBER
SIX, AB 179. CAN I PLEASE HAVE A
MOTION? SENATOR SKINNER MOVES.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB 179.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED. SEN
WIENER I WIENER. AYE. MILO. NO.
MILO. NO. BECKER I BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. DOLLY
DURAZZO I. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
GROVE LAIRD I. LAIRD. AYE
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR AYE. NEWMAN
A NEWMAN. AYE. PADILLA I PADILLA
AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE. SEYARTO
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE WAHAB
I. WAHAB. AYE. WILK. AYE WILK.
AYE 113 FIVE. IS THAT WHAT? 14
ONE 1314 ONE. OKAY. THE VOTE IS
14 TO 1 AND THE ITEM IS OUT,
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB 181. CAN I
PLEASE HAVE A MOTION? SO MOVED,
MOVED BY SENATOR DOLE, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ÁP 181. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. SEN WIENER
WIENER. AYE. WIENER AYE. MILO.
MILO AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. DOLLY. DOLLY
AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN GROVE. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE
GROVE. AYE. LAIRD. AYE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. ROTH ROTH AYE.
SEYARTO CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WILK. AYE WILK.
AYE. WHAT'S THE VOTE? 18 TO 0.
THE ITEM IS OUT SO THAT AT LEAST
WE'RE DONE. OKAY, THAT COVERS
EVERYTHING. THANK YOU EVERYONE.
WE'RE ADJOURNED. NICE JOB.